russia has placed their nuclear forces
on high alert over the weekend and
there's a real concern that vladimir
putin would launch nuclear weapons now
they're calling it nuclear deterrence
which is to imply that they will only
fire in response but you look at what's
going on right now with the the russian
economy the ruble dropped around 30 or
so percent they kept their stock market
clock exchange closed so a lot of people
think that russia's in serious trouble
here but i don't believe that vladimir
putin would start a war unless he
intended to see it through and he likely
calculated these responses you had to he
had to predict they'd go after the banks
there would be sanctions they've already
sanctioned him in the past so we'll see
where all this goes they
have put their nuclear weapons on high
alert we're now hearing that brazil has
announced i should say bolsonaro at
least of brazil announced neutrality
switzerland has broken neutrality which
is kind of crazy to sanction russia
china's obviously on the side of russia
and we're starting to see more and more
people take sides belarus is expected to
join the war on the side of russia
and it just seems like things may spiral
out of control but maybe not maybe the
sanctions will actually work so we'll
talk about this there's a real fear we
got an article from barrens um it's
actually kind of funny they say that the
the removing banks from the swift
international payment system could
result in cyber attacks and these are
the ten stocks we think that will go up
because of it gotta love capitalism so
we'll get into all that we do have some
cyber attacks we do have some news
around basically everything that will uh
all of this stuff as well as a funny
story of jill biden accidentally calling
kamala harris the president although i
don't know if it's an accident at this
point and we'll get into all that
joining us today to talk about this is
lauren southern pleasure to be here
thanks for having me you want to
introduce yourself yeah i'm lauren
southern i am a documentary filmmaker
completely cancelled all over the world
like a lot of people here i'm sure so no
we're good no you're just me all right
we're fine um yeah
i came here from canada all the way
going canada i'm glad to escape briefly
from our dictatorship so that's been
good they're not going to let you back
in when they see this now yeah they're
going to be like hey that's her
dictatorship i was told to be on good
behavior while i was here
but you've done a lot of reporting
before you did reporting
at the rebel right yeah i was at rebel
media and then i did a bunch of
independent on the ground stuff we
certainly crossed paths a few times at
protests in europe um
then i took a bit of a break from media
and i'm back working on a few movies
i had uh borderless farmlands crossfire
and my new one is american mirage
interesting what is that one about uh
it's about the caravans and illegal
migration into the us we should we
definitely talk about that because i
don't know if you heard that uh the us
government issued a memo requesting
customs and border protection leave the
southern border to go to poland to
process refugees from ukraine
and it's like a job anyone can do and
there's no reason to take our border
guards off to do it so especially when
there's not enough there they've given
up on trying to protect the border
because they've got so many people just
working on processing people or is that
the policy of the bite administration to
have no border yeah it's it's half and
half i mean when you want to get into
the documentary you will but all right
we also
have shades you missed me don't even
silence we missed you
they were calling begging for me to come
back it's true it's true we were and i
am glad to be here i thought you know
what i'll do them a favor i'll head back
over to the cast castle and i also
couldn't be separated from you lovely
folks at home i missed you all so much
seamus coughlin of freedom tunes i
release animated cartoons on my youtube
channel every single week sometimes
twice a week we got a funny one coming
out this thursday so i hope you all will
check it out and subscribe and i am
looking forward to this conversation
when when you when you see uh lauren
southern on the camera behind her is
this very beautiful uh wooden tim cass
sign by any guest okay uh and sheamus
who cares about things being done
properly i guess i think it's funny that
you know
world war three is breaking out and
we're we're doing silly jokes about cast
and sheamus i mean we can't stop joking
right it's true humor is part of being
human
that's kind of the center point or one
of maybe eating is another one of them
hey i'm glad you're here lauren i'm
happy to be here i um i you were like uh
focusing on my immigration way before i
realized the danger and then i started
studying like roman history the history
the fall of the roman empire and stuff
and and how basically unfettered
immigration is the reason that that fell
any any country that just lets other
cultures come in and then set up shop
and create the government is now that
government yeah i've never understood
the reaction to my conversations about
immigration people always just lose
their minds this is racism uh immigrant
is code word for like anyone that's not
white to you and that's why you don't
want mass immigration and i'm like
anywhere except the west i am a liberal
i'm like far left if you go to
anywhere in asia anywhere in africa even
if you go just down to mexico they're
like
nope no foreigners in close these
borders we want to protect our own first
and i'm like all right we just need to
you know slow it down a bit and that's
racist here i'm a i'm a liberal by
non-western standards but you're far
right if you're living in america and
say these things yeah we got lady
pressing the buns i am pushing buttons
in the corner i have a lovely lady here
with me tonight i'm very excited i
always love that feminine energy it's
gonna be a great chat i'm excited before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support our work as a member you'll get
access to exclusive segments from this
show that go monday through thursday at
11 p.m so we'll have one an exclusive
episode with lauren up later tonight you
won't want to miss it and you keep our
journalists employed but don't forget
also to smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and i just want to point out as
well i made that comment about you like
world war three is coming i don't know
if world war three is really coming we
have a serious conflict in europe i just
think it's funny that we're at this
point in time
where you have uh you know a group of
people of varying political backgrounds
are are here on to do a podcast and have
a very serious discussion and it's like
yes yes the situation in ukraine is
growing very dire so smash that like
button subscribe so that culture around
youtube where it's like this exaggerated
youthful exuberance is now being you
know it's it's a part of
war with russia no it's true if you when
you look at news reports from the 1940s
and like we need to help our boys who
are overseas and then when people look
back on our conflicts like hit the like
button subscribe come check our channel
vladimir putin just shelled a mall
killing civilians smash that like button
did you guys see the applebee's
commercial yes i was like
wait what what was this apple oh you got
to see it
so there's air raid sirens going off in
in ukraine
and then all of a sudden it just breaks
to like this cowboy guy doing a butt
shuffle dance and it's like cold beer on
a friday night and it's like
wings wait this is an actual applebee's
commercial it was on like yeah which
channel was it on cnn cnn was showing a
live shot
and then it cuts to an album
and then it's just a little window with
the air raid sirens in the corners like
live ukraine air raid sirens and the big
applebees i guess applebee's got pissed
and they announced they're like pulling
ads or whatever
anyway let's let's let's let's get see
i'm sorry i mean i'm surprised anyone
saw that it was on cnn you know right
well that's true but it went viral on
twitter wherever everyone mocked them
well let's talk about this uh this first
story and uh we have this from cnn of
all outlets i like using cnn when
something like this white house responds
to russia's decision to put deterrence
forces on high alert
they say white house secretary jen sachi
said sunday that russian president
vladimir putin's decision to put
russia's deterrence forces which include
nuclear arms and high alert are part of
a wider pattern of unprovoked escalation
and manufactured threats from the
kremlin this is really a this is really
a pattern that we've seen from president
putin through the course of this
conflict which is manufacturing threats
that don't exist in order to justify
further aggression and the global
community and the american people should
look at it through the through that
prism sachi told abc's george
stephanopoulos on this week
well the news there is that in response
to the sanctions the escalation and i
guess what putin says is aggressive
language towards russia they've put all
of their uh forces on high alert which
includes nuclear weapons and then you
had this guy on russian tv who said
what's the point something like what's
the purpose of the world without russia
in it and then said we've got 500
nuclear submarines we can launch these
warheads and you know we could basically
wipe out nato in the u.s i guess the
question is saber rattling hyperbole or
should we all go hide in the basement
there's absolutely going to be nukes
dropped you think so hassan [ __ ] just
said there wouldn't oh
here we go my man's reversed nostradamus
we're screwed we're just done for guys i
want to launch them on mars i think if
you nuked the poles on mars doesn't that
start an atmosphere or something do you
think russia is that that you know it's
funny that maybe you could work together
yeah what's funny about the north pole
they can take the south pole it has like
one percent of what of like relevance to
the conversation i know i'm just trying
to make it better i'm kind of you are
talking about news
i hope there's the right place why would
anyone do it it seems like if you
launched a nuke that would be the end of
everything no i disagree the surface you
don't think the surface would just get
fried after that u.s did it they got
away with this drop of food that was
before anyone else had yeah that was
before i see
so look the the fear is mutually assured
destruction right
not real i don't believe in it i don't
think it's a real thing
so you guys have to see that movie with
um was it matthew broderick no war games
war games
yeah and like all the missiles are like
flying in the air or whatever and then
there was gi joe you guys ever see the
gi joe
where
the guy who looks like the pope plays
the villain what
no i didn't see him yeah he was the guy
the guy from game of thrones who was the
priest guy plays a villain and then he's
like the us fires their nukes and then
so then every other country's like what
are you doing and they'll fire the nukes
and they see all the nukes in the air
and then the cobra guy masquerading as
the president blows up the u.s nukes so
that everyone else does
mutual research destruction makes no
sense to me right let me ask you a
question lauren let me ask you a
question
uh so a military officer comes to you
and he says
mrs southern
17 nuclear warheads are headed towards
the eastern seaboard there is nothing we
can do to stop them but
you can choose to kill 10 million
civilians yourself would you do it would
you be like i guess i'll blow up a bunch
of civilians
you know if i was a little more [ __ ]
and spiteful maybe but you know maybe no
no not well it depends on how the
patreon lawsuits well but think about it
yeah
it would be like which cities are we
talking about do i get to like and
choose let's just say you know like we
can
russia has fired a bunch of nukes at the
eastern seaboard the united states
uh vancouver and toronto included i
guess cause you know canada um
you can't stop it but you can kill
russian civilians would you do it
i don't i don't think yeah i don't think
i don't know here's the thing i don't
know if she would but someone would yes
that's that's a good point i think that
threat exists in the mind of anyone
who's considering launching nukes in the
first place but you guys ever hear that
story about the russian submarine dude
they got a false alarm yes that nuke was
fired and he refused to fire save the
world i think that's more indicative of
what a person would do
well there's been studies done on this
too with like just the amount of people
in war that go out whether it be
afghanistan or world war ii and they'll
talk about how much they freeze it's
like the first time it's almost like i'm
making this up on the spot fake stats
but something i read said like 50 of the
time they'll freeze and not be able to
shoot someone the first time it happens
to them we talked about this with
someone with vietnam they were saying
that the soldiers were drafted would aim
up and try not to hit people yes
actually most soldiers there was a study
done called men under fire and they
basically found that something like two
percent of soldiers did 98 of the
killing whoa yeah and so the entire idea
was our government wanted to figure out
how you could get everyday average
troops to be willing to fight because
most people in a combat situation if
someone is up on top of them or they
have to kill them in a direct
self-defense scenario will do so so in
warfare if the enemy are jumping into
your trenches yes you'll shoot them more
often than not but if they're all the
way across the battlefield and you're
trying to snipe and pick them off most
soldiers won't pull the trigger and our
government kind of tried to
figure out ways to encourage troops to
do so didn't video games help
i'm not sure yeah there's a game called
america's army that was basically
grooming people to become soldiers
not that um there's a misconception that
government i'm not saying
it makes you more violent
but when you're desensitized to entering
combat what i i was reading something
where they said like playing video games
helped people overcome their like
resistance towards killing someone
i think probably with drones and stuff
it's a lot easier the further and
further like degrees apart it's almost
like the um trolley question
okay would you pull the thing to kill
one person or two people all right would
you push someone in front of the train
to stop the trolley the closer you get
to being the exact thing that kills the
person that's when all those mental
blocks start but when they're just green
light on a screen much easier to click a
button my favorite trolley meme is the
one where
it's one track and it's just riddled
with people and it says you can stop the
train at the trolley at any time but it
would hurt corporate profits
that one's good by the way it was also
it was men against fire was the name of
it men against five yeah and yeah so yes
um and i want to double check the
numbers i threw out i i may have
misremembered them so go and look that
up for yourself i got the name of this
shockingly low number of people are
willing to actually engage in that the
russian um submarine soldier his name
was vasily archipov and it's during the
height of the cold war uh cuban missile
crisis and he got i think there was a
miscalculation they thought the nukes
had been fired he got an order to fire
and he didn't do it basically prevented
world war three that's one guy yeah and
he's like he's like a hero right yeah
they're like this guy i don't i don't i
don't think most people would do it but
would vladimir putin is a question and i
think vladimir putin would fire nick's
if he was fired on yeah no no i think he
would i think
yeah i think vladimir putin would launch
nukes really well look at they're not
really sending they're like people are
giving the ukrainians weapons but no
one's sending troops in they're kind of
just like oh we don't really want to get
involved we don't want to get in trouble
so he's
i don't know the man might get away with
it i saw a cartoon meme of the ukraine
guy and they were the american guy i was
like you have my gun and the other guy's
like you have my the the scandinavian i
was like you have my axe and then the
british guy was like you have my bow and
then it shows the the ukrainian guy and
he's just got an axe a bow and a sword
yeah
also i just want to pull something up
real quick so i can uh add some clarity
what i was saying earlier the best
figures i have right now say that
according to the study it was fewer than
15 to 20 of soldiers fired their weapon
in the first place and then an even
lower number actually killed people but
with my yeah no but i also want to say
with my number about two percent
actually doing 90 of the killing i'm
actually i'm not seeing that here i
imagine most soldiers aren't in combat i
believe most soldiers are doing like
logistics are back behind the scenes are
you talking about just combat soldiers i
believe well i mean i i believe that the
study is referring to combat soldiers
because that's the reason they would i
mean it's the entire reason they were
doing the research right
wow smackdown now sheamus giving me a
nice no i'm sorry i didn't no no no no
no no no no you could actually i could
be completely wrong i'm saying this is
what i'm a man
so the question is why is vladimir putin
invading ukraine and if you can answer
that you can answer whether or not he's
willing to use nukes more
more accurately so there's a you know
there's the conspiracy theories they uh
maybe not even conspiracy is the right
word but there is the theory that
vladimir putin opposes the davos group
world economic forum liberal economic
order and all that stuff and
it's not an issue of nato which is
proven by the fact that estonia and
latvia are on the border with russia as
well and their nato nations the issue is
that ukraine is you know joining the
liberal economic order or whatever and
putin's actually directly criticized
this
i don't actually think that's the
principal reason though if that was the
reason then you could argue well he's
got to stop the globalists so of course
he'll use nukes right there there are
people posting this there was a crazy a
ukrainian mp went on fox news and said
they're fighting for the new world order
and so yeah and so this is a lot of
people saying like that proves it i got
a really simple solution for all of you
guys the us and nato have been screwing
with russian oil profits
it's it's it's like kind of that simple
right yeah i'm not sure that russia care
about profits as much as we think they
do i think they've got especially in the
east they have different values than we
do in the west in a sense they've got
those blood and soil values more than we
do they've got the spiritual values they
genuinely believe like the ukrainians
are spiritually connected to russia i
interviewed a guy named michael
millerman really interesting case he's
got a phd on alexander dugan who they've
called uh putin's brain he's a phd on
dugan it's it's in like eurasianism or
around that topic but he studied and
translated alexander dugan that was like
his focus of his work yeah and he had 12
professors helping him out with the phd
11 of them quit because they said this
is too dangerous you shouldn't be
allowed to study this topic it's
because he partakes in something called
strategic empathy where he really wants
to understand the russian perspective
and like
be able to empathize for the purpose of
understanding and everyone said no this
is disgusting how can you have such an
illiberal worldview and now he's getting
calls from all over the world of people
like what is going on please explain
eurasianism to us and he's
well then
that's the issue then if if uh you know
we mentioned ben shapiro's uh tweet he
said russia you know putin wants to
rebuild the empire yes sanctions aren't
going to deter someone who's
ideologically driven right if if putin
is driven by ideology i believe he he
can and will use nukes
i mean
maybe i shouldn't say will he he's he's
uh capable of he's what i mean to say is
he's the he's the kind of person who i
believe has the capability and the uh
willpower to put it i'm not saying it's
a good thing to press the button and say
i will get what i want you know what i
mean yeah people are reasonable when
they're driven by these
temporal things of you know money day to
day i just want to stay safe but when
you're at that higher level where it's
like even something like revenge or this
is a spiritual battle then you get
people that'll blow themselves up in
stadiums for it yeah but i think you
know uh to elaborate on the profit
motive thing i i'm not saying it's like
putin wants money and he's like where's
my money my oil it's more like getting
resources for russia yeah i agree with
that so
you know what i see is we we mentioned
it 50 million times you got the cutter
turkey pipeline you've got the the
corrupt energy dealings joe biden was
doing in in in ukraine with with why i
should say his son and then his
intervention with the government and
putin's like look we we support the
russian people selling oil to our
customers in europe we charge what we
can charge the west doesn't like those
prices so they're playing dirty games
like funding uh funding or providing
resources to rebels in syria and then
playing dirty games with barisma joe
biden's on camera saying if you don't
fire the prosecutor not in the billion
dollars turns out the prosecutor was
investigating the founder of barisma
whereas someone's on the board conflict
of ventures the very least putin's like
you're screwing with my ability to
generate resources for my country and my
people so that's that's less of an
ideological and more of like looking at
you know a world leader thing but i
wonder if it is more ideological than
well you know i in it's difficult to say
i can't read putin's mind i think
there's an argument to be made that it
isn't ideological uh that it is more or
less from russia's standpoint a security
issue whereas from america's standpoint
it's an ideological issue so we see this
as we would like for
ukraine to become a more liberalized
nation which is part of nato
and which is part of the eu and from
putin's perspective it's as soon as they
become a nato country the united states
could put military bases there and it's
an entirely different set of concerns
from i either want to make more money or
i want to expand my nation yeah and this
would be like the last point if they do
think that the u.s are going to build
troops up there and they do think nato
is going to join then they're like we
have this short window that we have to
invade and actually be successful and
it's got to be now um i want to
i want to ask you guys oh god did i just
forget the question i was going to ask
you guys
it's gone
away it's coming back i actually got a
buzz in my ear on the new world order
just said no no
no
so there was a um this video on fox
maybe i should pull it up actually where
this uh actually i don't know if anybody
wrote about it i'd have to find it on
twitter cool i just remembered my
questions
um
i didn't know this until recently but in
some polling like 80 to 90 of people in
crimea wanted to go back and be a part
of russia and i know people have said
like oh the russians
specifically sent people to live there
to try and make it a russian majority
and have that happen but then they've
got the same thing in donetsk where
there are a lot of people that want to
be a part of russia
do you think that they should be allowed
to have some sort of
vote referendum like quebec did in
canada to join russia or is that a
problem okay i want to reason and
self-determination
but people are saying it's malicious and
russia russia is specifically sending
people there so like
let's look at open borders groups if
they specifically had a bunch of
mexicans go into california and then
said we want to have a referendum to see
if uh california wants to be a part of
mexico how would you feel about that
uh well put well i mean i gotta be
honest that's that's war that's a type
of war tim would say california they can
have it yeah
that's what i said you take them very
you picked a very interesting state
there lauren like no i gotta say
whatever even though the things
california is known for are basically
useless they do produce what what
they're not far known for is useful
which is producing food yeah a lot of
almonds too yeah uh well here's here's
the question though
the the the issue with
the uh donbass region dinettes
what some people have told us and again
i know it's fog of war propaganda it's
hard to know what's what's true is that
uh it was ukrainian and then during the
soviet union holodomor russification the
eastern regions became predominantly
more ethnically russian as opposed to
ukrainian now 30 years on all of a
sudden it's like well there's a lot of
russians people you know speakers here
guess russia should take it
i guess the question is how fair how far
back do you want to go
what what is the you know
what is the issue here with with the the
eastern region of ukraine if it was the
soviet union if there was an empire it
collapsed there are some questions about
boundaries and borders and stuff sure
california's a little different if
california is allowing people to come in
as non-citizens and then
you know they have kids who then become
citizens and within 18 or 20 years they
vote for secession you've got a serious
question about whether or not there's an
intentional act to come in and take take
land away from the united states uh
that being said there's still an
important question of if they if they
play by the rules if they're working
within the law if these people are
citizens and they vote to secede and
join mexico
do we do we respect the wishes of
secession and this country was founded
on a bunch of people being like we
hereby vote you know we like we're not
part of the you know the royal the
british empire anymore and britain was
like nah and they fought over it so
maybe that's what happens is like
both sides will claim they're right
whoever has the has the ability to
defend themselves or reconquer the land
you might say like they have like some
ethical
justification to say we're going to be
part of mexico now but realistically the
u.s government's not going to give up
their west coast all that water
well that's that's why tim brought
warfare into it too it would be a
question of would mexico be be capable
of going to war with the united states
military and the answer to that question
is almost certainly no unless there was
an ally in another part of the world who
wanted to send their troops in to help
so china said let's destabilize the
region and
you are you're wrong oh i am wrong
explain you got to understand man um
with what we're looking at in russia
a bunch of regular people with guns
almost impossible to conquer
oh that's true air superiority does does
nothing for holding for occupying
territory you can't occupy street
corners with fighter jets that's true
right
afghanistan now exactly
our artillery is not going to hold down
uh it's not going to force people to you
know go to certain buildings or to not
go near certain buildings certainly you
can blow the cities up okay well sure
but what's the what then what's the goal
there so well
if you're trying to conquer or maintain
control of a land blowing it up and
wiping it off the map it's kind of like
well we're losing it anyway let's cart
let's blanket sweep and just wipe
everything out and rebuild later maybe
but you're not going to be able to
control the people here's why i'm still
correct because oh boy because
you are correct i mean firstly a
defensive war is always easier and less
expensive to fight than an invasion is
however
it would depend on what percentage of
california wanted to be a part of mexico
and how many people there would actually
be willing to fight alongside the united
states government to maintain that
territory as part of the us i don't
think it's just a question of the u.s
coming in and blowing things up
yeah it's it's uh if there was enough
sentiment in california for secession
and i actually think there there might
like i said like
around a third to 40 of people in like
each of the five regions of the us are
you know favor secession of their region
so uh the question is how many people
support the session how many people
oppose it and how many people don't care
and if you look at uh like democrats to
republicans in california it's two to
one it's like for every two democrats
there's one republican and then
independents are people who are more
likely to say i don't care yeah so
i kind of think that you'd
if if it was uh a democrat secession
which is what people are actually
talking about and what you know the
podesta what the boston globe story they
were wargaming out what happens after
the 2020 election if trump won they were
suggesting the west coast secede
it's it's a it's a left democrat
secession movement whether or not the
united states
can can stop it from happening
i'm not entirely convinced they could
you know we we can talk about you know
what did putin say i'm sorry what did
biden say if you want to go up against
us you need nuclear weapons that's not
true are you talking about bombing like
civilians populations with nuclear bombs
otherwise
you can't do anything yeah destroying a
country is different than taking and
conquering a country so i propaganda is
like the most important thing well and
it's the entire reason they want to
disarm people
oh yeah absolutely yeah isn't it amazing
watching all of the
like lefties go full soy over the
ukrainians being armed
yeah you mean like in support of yeah
look at all these normal individuals
boss babe with her gun and i'm like yeah
that's cool i love that but why don't
you want that for us
because the second amendment isn't about
oh i want to go to the shooting range
and have some fun or if this happens i
think this might be waking a lot of
people up to that and realizing like
yeah we need to be armed
look at our southern border we should
have access to it southern borders
porous what do we have like a million
encounters last year or more oh yeah and
it would be way more than what were
counted i you know i was just down there
and i was watching every day i i was
like i counted a million i counted a
million myself no i was i i literally
just drove to uh one random part on the
other side of a country club in in
mcallen texas stayed there one morning
at 4 am got out of my car and there were
traffickers walking by and they're like
don't film my stunt phil mess and i'm
like holy like you can just drive
anywhere across the border and see
people making a little journey
nice wild
how can you what electric fence is can
we do something like that's inhumane
okay so here was the issue is there was
a texas country club there was the wall
and then it just stopped and there was a
texas country club i guess they couldn't
buy the land so all of these human
traffickers and gang members were just
going to this country club on the side
of mcallen
i guess not because they're so they they
just go they go around 4 a.m they say
there's uh shift switches at that time
with the border guards and they're just
kind of lazy and
you know a little more lethargic so
they'll just go across at 4am go through
the night this is this is why
um
mentality culture psychology is so
important for a war effort if the united
states it has a has a large quantity of
people who don't care about their
borders
and even the people employed to guard
the borders don't care about the borders
then yang got a border absolutely and
then you i mean so so you know we got
into talking about this because of the
issue of the eastern region of ukraine
where you have people voting to to you
know be annexed by russia or to succeed
or whatever in crimea that's basically
how russia gained control of it they
were like oh we had a referendum and
everybody voted
there was a poll from several years ago
like well before the annexation and it
found that it was the most pro-russia
portion of ukraine that they basically
were like we're russia we're not ukraine
but we're legally ukraine so i can
believe that a lot of people there want
to be part of russia i don't know if i
believe the referendum was legit you
know i mean like putin comes in he had
tanks ready and then it's just there but
i do think it's interesting we're
talking about guns with ukrainian
citizens i i the question i have i guess
is
if these these these like liberal types
not leftists left us like guns these
liberal types are cheering like occupy
democrats cheered for the distribution
of 18 000 i think it was you know select
fire collision cops full auto rifles
you you said like why don't you want
that for us and i'm like it's an
interesting question why do they want
ukraine's borders protected and the
people armed and they want the people of
the united states disarmed and our
borders porous and weak because they
want russia broken because they're
they're russia phobes because they
listen to the media russia folks yeah
they're russia there's a lot of russia
okay
sorry i'll let you finish that and then
i'll go to my article
it seems like the liberal people that
are acting like this is is a fractal
behavior of the liberal economic order
which has literally gone around the
world setting up military bases and
disarming countries like japan after
world war ii arguably justified i don't
know um but the fact that they would be
like stand down get rid of your nukes
ukraine
like that's that's basically what these
liberal people are trying to do to
american citizens get rid of your
weapons guy like there's fallen orders
fall on the path you know they're
mindlessly whatever it is is that is
that going to be an effective human
civilization a bunch of sheep just
bleating about and then just eating
grass no i think diversity and con and
like um resistance is more effective if
you look in nature that seems to be what
helps nature grow competition helps
advancements yeah you need a reason to
want to work for to go go forward you
just go forward because that's what
happens you got to want it yeah okay can
i
read you this headline yeah so talking
about russia phobia first of all i want
to point out if you watch movies you can
always have a russian villain you can
always have like an easter egg i'd even
just say a villain from eastern europe
and no one really cares right they're
like oh yeah that's fine but if you have
a villain that's you know
i mean you could maybe do this ten years
ago but a muslim or something people
will lose their mind
there was an article in the globe and
mail today that said russians in the
sports world are doing pr for putin's
war machine
um
and they're talking about alex ovechkin
hockey player
and i'm sure do you guys see the tennis
player that wrote no war on the camera
yeah so in this article they're saying
all of that is pro-russia we need to
basic these athletes are all pro-putin
because they just said no war they
didn't say we hate putin wow and it's
like a full-on like hardcore kind of
anti-russian article and they're talking
about russians that are saying they
don't want a war and saying no enough of
that there was an nbc
i think it was nbc ex-executive that
said we need to start kicking russian
students out of america we need to start
seizing their property
and i'm like there are you know there
are thousands of russians protesting
against this war
like russians are not putin you see
someone vandalized it was like a russian
uh club or something like russian
american club somewhere like smashed out
the windows
they've banned all russian vodka
and canada that's right canada yeah in
lcbo i went and got a bunch of russian
standard vodka because they took it off
the shelves two hours after i
shake it up yeah the russian bath house
in manhattan is like the best bath house
in the world whoa whoa whoa whoa are you
broke putin yeah wait hold on let me go
tim we got to experience the spanish flu
and now we're getting to experience cold
war anti-russian xenophobia
you know you gotta get
spice of life i guess yeah
we we had um that video from alex jones
where he was saying it's like a world
war one world war ii build-up and he he
accurately predicted i mean as much as
he he predicted it he said back in uh i
think it was october that there would be
a big war in february so you have to
wonder yes yes where's that jar do you
have that jar somewhere oh it's
downstairs alex jones was right jar yeah
yeah he's going to be he's more like
there should be more money in there
already he has a lot of good context
because that was some good info
apparently but i also if you look at
like the way the world um inflation is
going you can kind of predict a conflict
on the horizon back a couple years oh
yeah yep price price increases predict
all this stuff so you look at what's
happening in the u.s and you've got all
the tensions already and now i i mean
and on top of that the the russia phobia
or whatever you want to call it has been
around since 2015 like they're the the
boogeyman and villain phobe russophobe
but it's but it's but it's a big
component of the culture
as well no no so look look
you get people saying you're a russian
bot you support russia they say tucker
carlson is pushing russian talking
points and it's like what tucker carlson
say he said here's what the west is
doing in ukraine here's what putin is
saying and they're like ah he supports
putin yeah so what's happening
internationally is also a big component
of the culture war you add into the fact
that we already have terrible inflation
now this conflict is going to make gas
prices worse energy in europe is going
to get worse
escalating prices for energy and food
and then
shelter these precipitate major
conflicts internally yeah so
i gotta say man it just feels like
everything's kind of falling i was
thinking about how um you say cultures
or politics downstream from culture and
i was like yeah really i want to help
the world if i was trying to get
everyone fresh water and internet if i
do that for someone that's the enemy of
someone else that someone else is gonna
be really mad at me that's right because
that's gonna help them grow and produce
more humans but if i'm an entertainer
and that person is watching my movies
their enemies don't care in fact their
enemies are probably also watching my
movies that's the beauty of
entertainment it connects people osama
bin laden was playing final fantasy vii
he played animal crossing what
absolutely he was a human being who
played like
they don't
humanization is a problem like if you
come out and you talk about why does
vladimir putin want to do this what are
his intentions then you're pro putin
like that's literally what they said
about tucker carl well this is that that
phd guy i was talking about it terrifies
me how little we understand so in china
in russia they understand us very well
we do not understand the east but they
get us you'll see it even china will
come out and they'll be like go to the
united nations and they'll be like oh
look at america we need to deal with
america's racism problem george floyd
woohoo like as if they aren't super
racist there a lot of people anyways
obviously not all um
and there's definitely a an
unwillingness to understand them because
it's like that's humanization you have
to leave them as inhuman if you even try
to understand the eastern perspective
then you're pro putin you're pro china
um it also scares me and i wanted to
kind of talk about this quickly if you
guys are willing to but
when we talk about making political
decisions in the west it's on a
four-year cycle it's just based on
election cycles with putin with china
russia it's all like hundred year cycles
you've seen china with the south china
sea that's been a hundred year plan
we're gonna slowly take this we're gonna
work on this and putin how long has
putin been at least 20 years yeah he's
been in office ages but they're looking
for a long time we're not so they're
like uh short-term pain economically now
for ukraine what's that looking like in
50 years for us that's how they're
thinking well there's a terrifying
reality in that
to an extent authoritarianism is
efficient
the problem is the problem is if you're
uh
people always get mad at me when i say
that and i'm like it is that doesn't
mean it's effective
efficient different so here's what i
mean let's say you're you're in a car
and you're driving straight towards the
edge of a cliff and there's one guy in
charge and every single time someone
screams and yells we're headed for the
cliff he says shut up i'm driving you go
off a cliff just just just it was it was
fast it got the job done real quick and
then not effective
if you had everybody in the car arguing
over what to do
you know eventually someone screams and
says you've got to turn and everyone
says turn and say okay fine and they
turn you know go off the cliff so the
decentralized system of power things can
be sluggish but in i think you're
offered up more opportunity for averting
disaster with someone like vladimir
putin he can move very quickly in a
single direction
china can move very quickly in a single
direction they can wipe out a whole
bunch of houses and then build a highway
that sucks for the average person and
then what happens is centralized power
limits your pers your ability to to see
what's going on a decentralized network
of humans who are running something can
come up with way more solutions and then
eventually the meritocratic solution
finds its way to the top not always with
authoritarianism you got one really
smart person you know a philosopher king
or a despot either way they can say
don't do this it will be bad for us but
they also are just one person not the
smartest person in the world and they're
not able to see everything and they'll
miss you know you put it this way 99
problems they find one they solve it
very quickly it's efficient in the long
run they miss out on all the other ones
so i think decentralization is the
safest path forward but vladimir putin
china they're able to but is it the
safest when you are competing against
people that can move quickly because i
think it's the safest on a worldwide
scale but not when you have competitors
that can go like i think there's another
answer here i mean i i don't think it's
so black and white so i agree with you
that it's a huge issue that our thinking
is so short term in the united states i
don't necessarily believe that long-term
thinking is incompatible with a
decentralized system you just have to
have a population that is virtuous and
intelligent enough to want to make
decisions that will be better for the
future so as it happens our culture is
really bad
at cultivating virtue and encouraging
people to move in a direction where they
will make sacrifices today for a better
future tomorrow if we were better at
doing that we wouldn't need some kind of
insane authoritarian system for people
to make decisions that would actually be
good for their children so a really good
point is when you have a unified culture
you could theoretically have a despot
but no one cares because they all agree
with the direction the culture is going
in
so if the people if the people of russia
are all like we like what putin is doing
it's part of our you know our beliefs
and our ideology
are they really going to be upset
obviously there are people protesting
i'm not saying they aren't i'm saying if
everybody in china agrees with chinese
communism and are willing to make
sacrifices for the greater culture then
well i think we're happy with it i think
part of the problem is and so for the
united states even though we've always
had these four-year election cycles for
the presidency
we were able to progress towards
goals that took us quite a long time and
that was because for the most part we
were on the same page culturally a
different political party
taking power from the political party
that was just in power for four to eight
years didn't really mean the country was
going to move in a radically different
direction so you could achieve things
that would take decades and decades to
achieve because no matter who you voted
for they'd be interested in that now the
difference between the left is so
massive and we
completely disagree on what's good for
the country and so that does mean every
single time power changes hands our
country moves in a completely different
direction we can never make any real
progress well let's let me let me
clarify that see i think you had a
little bias there sheamus you're
assuming they're operating based on
what's better for the country they
aren't no they're not objectively not i
would agree that they're not i mean if
you're for uh open borders if you're for
non-citizens voting if you oppose the
constitution you're literally not for
this country no i i agree no no no look
here's the issue i never said there for
the country
you said
i'm i'm being somewhat facetious but you
said you said deciding on what's best
for the country oh yes they're not
they're they're actually arguing what's
worse for the country they think i would
agree i would agree so but here's my
issue
i have if you're if you're of the
opinion that america sucks and the wokar
and it should be dissolved or destroyed
or overturned or dramatically altered or
should be a revolution fine just say it
just come out and be like we hate this
place and i'll be like all right like
just be honest with me about it well and
that's the thing a lot of them do and
then we're still willing to engage in
conversation with them about what
direction the country should move in
well i mean like the democrats like the
actual
political class and the neocons of
course i don't want the democrats and
the neocons though it's been like a
fascinating trend to watch some of the
people that hate this country the most
be right-wing nationalists
have you not seen the memes where people
are like
hey you're a fascist you're a bigot
you're a white male we hate you and then
hey man come and go to war with russia
with us and they're like no
f you i hope you die yes like like
they're like i hate this country now i
hope it collapses um john doyle did a
whole post on it and he's like you know
this is
we're in a regime that is conquered by a
globalist liberal power and it's crazy
to see you know nationalists being super
against america well so uh interestingly
i uh stephen marsh we had him on the
show he wrote the book the next civil
war he made he he summarized in a way i
hadn't heard someone summarize it i
think he nailed it he said within the
united states there's a multicultural
democracy and a constitutional republic
and they can't co-exist and i was like
oh you nailed it i mean that explains i
mean they want to get rid of the
electoral college which would be
devastating insane yeah they they
they're for open borders to a great
degree i don't you know they always come
out and they nitpick it's like no to a
great degree they um they've been you
know the democratic establishment's been
smuggling my migrant children illegal
immigrant children across the country on
planes on military planes they're very
much at odds they don't believe in the
constitution then they but here's the
issue i take
if you want a multicultural democracy
okay present your case make your
argument go vote let's let's let's have
that conversation um
the problem is the lying they come out
and they say we're for this country and
the constitution let 800 000
non-citizens yeah new york and you're
like they're not citizens that's the
same and so
being for the country and being for the
constitution are different because the
federal reserve was formed literally the
bank of international settlements this
is like a mind worm in our system it's
been in there for like over 100 years
and that is the country so i don't love
that but i love the constitution no no
but hold on look ian if a brain slug
landed on your head and took over your
body i wouldn't say well i guess ian's
got to go i'd be like get rid of them
because you know me but everyone that
saw me be like hey ian's acting crazy
right that's right and it's been 100
years or whatever or like so you have to
detect what the virus is all pointed out
i want to point this out tim you're
talking about the fact that these people
will not come out and say that they hate
the united states of america and at some
point and i'm sure you agree with this
i'm sure i'm not going to get much
pushback here but we'll see at some
point they don't really have to it's
like that person who tells you they
don't hate someone but then every single
thing they say about them is bad and
whenever they talk about the goodness
that they might potentially find in that
person they say well they could improve
in this way they could hold themselves
to the actual standards that they've
said like okay you hate them and i'm not
going to be all that surprised if you're
actually rooting for their downfall
instead of trying to make them better
because everything you say about them is
critical all the time criticizing them
in good faith is different than
criticization
i agree with you the issue is there are
a lot of conservatives there are a lot
of moderates and libertarians who think
that the left is being honest when they
say these things
like uh you know so again to throw it
back to the conversation with stephen
marsh i said
you know in california they tried
repealing their civil civil rights
legislation or provision from their
constitution you know they they actually
are in favor of segregation he goes yeah
well they're saying so were you and i'm
like and they're lying well they say
they're saying you're lying and i'm like
yes but they literally tried to pass a
proposition to repeal the civil rights
language in their constitution i didn't
and i'm not i'm not sitting here
advocating for any conservative to do
that either i'm saying hey don't
but the problem is for a regular person
you know he he was saying look i'm about
30 000 feet watching this thing and then
i'm like and you need to dig deeper to
see exactly who really is lying and
telling the truth that's what i want to
what's the mind worm what do you think
it is what do i think the mind the
liberal economic order
yeah i think it's the downfall of
liberalism right now i mean you've had
communism failed fascism failed
liberalism went forward and was
successful but it's something that it
may last longer but it's still coming to
the end of its life it's eating itself
is it classical
i want to respond to that so
liberalism is failing but not um as an
ideology unto itself communism fails
because communism is psychotic and
doesn't work
liberalism failed because liberalism
allows
the the malignancy to come within it but
is it the classical liberalism was
working and they changed the definition
of the word liberalism just reused it
for this new military but you have the
freedom to do that that's what he's
saying it allows the freedom for that
distortion because it allows so much
freedom and then here's what happens
when uh when i am weak i ask you for
freedom because that is according to
your principles and when i'm strong i
deny you freedom because it's according
to mine so what happens is we have these
liberals it's it's happening like true
liberals like classical liberals like
civil libertarians it's all of us when
we keep saying things like look i
understand this far leftist is saying
crazy things but i have to respect their
right to free speech and they go thank
you so much ban him he's a bigot and
then you get banned so we we all keep
playing fair and saying we have
principles so we want to uphold them and
they say thank you for doing that you
know not deleted a good example of how
that can also work uh in in your favor
in that situation like majid nawaz was
in prison for terror basically in egypt
for terrorism he's on joe rogan great
show you guys got to check this episode
of groundbreaking um and
it was uh amnesty international he was
like anti-authority anti-west you know
anti-everything he was like a terrorist
basically against the west and amnesty
international still wanted him free
because he was being unjustly held and
he was like why why does this
this idea of this liberty this western
thing want me free even though i want it
destroyed because that's the pre that's
the idea of freedom is that we protect
your right to protest the system and he
was never he'd never done any violence
you know he's just been talking about
let me let me let me pull this story up
because this is relevant to what we're
talking about this is a tweet from fox
news
not backing down ukrainian parliament
member on inspiring civilian resistance
we know that we not only fight for
ukraine we fight for this new world
order
actual a quote from um kira rudick and
the interesting thing is there's like
some articles that have kind of framed
it as though she was saying
the camera was a national post they were
like she was saying the invasion would
would precipitate a new world order or
something no she's saying she's fighting
for it but what is she referring to it
in the proper noun sense of the new
world order is or is she using this
phrase as a buzz phrase she heard
somewhere
i mean it's
obviously it's just even if it is just a
buzz phrase and she doesn't understand a
terrible language especially when you've
already got so many people that are like
oh look at george soros loves this this
is like nato this is this country is an
experimental country created to create
american bases and nato and spread
liberal ideology like terrible language
when you've already got people talking
about all of that
um
it is worth simply talking about the
fact that the the western ideology even
though it's morphed into something else
now what some people would call the new
world order some people would call this
amalgamation of
larger institutions it is constantly
wanting to spread itself to other
countries and ukraine is one of those
countries and if it's just western
values that it has that's great but if
it is getting this
mind worm of all the other things that
is causing america to
you know decay in a lot of ways then
that's that's a problem isn't it i don't
know about um you know the grand
conspiracy of the new world order i know
it's been said by several world leaders
i think george h.w bush said it the
night i think it's the same word as like
the deep state right it's like it exists
but it's not you know lizard people it's
like there are people that there are
people within the administration that
stay there even when presidents change
and that's very normal and people can
call it the deep state and they can mean
it as lizard people or they can just be
in it i've asked you here asked alex
jones what's the difference between the
deep state and the shadow government and
he was like the deep state basically the
administrative state the people that get
hired and stay there for 40 years and
they're not elected but they're on the
floor of congress but then the shadow
government is like a secretive kind of
global governance that's in place in
case of nuclear war that's going to take
take control
um that's what alex told me so
so here's the issue i take with this
whole like idea of the new world order
is there's a weird overlap between what
china is doing and people saying like
you know biden is a puppet of xi and
they want to bring chinese style social
credit systems here but then when it
comes to the russian invasion china's on
the side of russia and opposed to the us
and the u.s is desperate to like it's
like begging china please
not only us are you talking about this
invasion right now the bank so
switzerland you mentioned earlier
switzerland defied its neutrality
switzerland is the home of the bank of
international settlements which is the
central bank of central banks yep and
now it's fighting on the side of
against russia or whatever
here's what i mean like if there was a
which is it are we is china's influence
expanding around the world and now where
you know democrats went and met with
china and you know these these communist
party members and said wow look at the
the speed at which you can build a
highway this is one of the stories we've
heard they went there like how do we do
this and now you've got this happening
in the in the west or is it the liberal
economic order that wants to unify
united states western nations through
nato or whatever the european union both
can't be true right
to a certain degree there can be some
issues that's why i i'm like it needs to
be properly defined what it is is china
is or is the grand conspiracy that
russia's invasion was all part of the
conspiracy for the new ooh
how many levels of underwater backgammon
are we playing right exactly
or is it just like make it simple this
lady said something dumb because
she's dumb
you know or is she part of a secret plot
to overthrow the australian the
australian uh like health minister that
said this is all about
what what what what what what what was
called schwab calling it thank you lydia
world order thing no she didn't say new
work maybe she did yeah she's like this
is for the great reset and everyone was
playing that and it's like why are you
using these words yeah really they do
sound cool so maybe it could just be it
sounded cool like new world order sounds
cool really cool
and it can also literally just be for
publicity because then they they get
people talking about it and they go well
that's not how i meant it obviously you
insane conspiracy theorists but not
yours that's what they want that's in
this mind war that we are in fifth
generational warfare that's what they
want to happen is for people to
accidentally start saying we should do
what that other what they want them what
they want it's hard to believe anything
you watch nothing you watch or read
online it's like is this 12 levels of
irony is this a serious statement was it
a mistake even
watching this war live we always talked
about what would it be like if we had
instagram and twitter and everything
when world war ii was happening and now
we've got it and all we're getting is a
ton of fake information so we've got the
the ghost of kiev who
was actually
it was like a video game simulation
video that went viral
and then um
obviously you had the footage of or the
recording of the 13 people that were
allegedly killed on snake island by the
russian government and like awful but
then the russian i saw rt published an
article saying no we actually took them
captive here's a video of that and i'm
like oh my gosh
there's so much different information
being put out here what are you even
yeah look at this hold on hold on the
video showing ukrainian fighter pilot
shooting down a russian plane the ghost
of kyo kiev clip is from a video game
not a video of fighting in ukraine this
is from politifact
yeah yeah and there were even uh
left-wing articles i actually won't say
left-wing because i don't wanna i don't
like portraying it as left-wing versus
what right with russia versus ukraine
because ukraine is actually very
nationalist there are a lot of
right-wingers a lot of people that
support the majority of people are
supporting ukraine obviously this is an
invasion by russia but um
yeah there were
progressive articles saying actually
it's good as long as it's positive
misinformation and the ghost of kiev is
misinformation that is boosting morale
and i can see how there's an argument
for that but also like
no it's still misinformation yeah i
think i think um the truth we'll set you
free and and we should have honest
information and assessments and
understanding and people should be
motivated by that the problem is
you've got uh
you know i think within the parent
factions you can call it multicultural
multicultural democracy versus
constitutional republic one side favors
truth and discussion and pragmatism and
one side favors control yeah the the the
multicultural democracy faction is just
like everyone get in line the majority
rules and the constitutional republic is
make your argument state your case
i think it's like the truth about what
though because i understand why in the
truth but not only are you get to choose
how you want to demand what you want to
demand but you also have to decide what
it is that you're what it is that you're
going to demand about like
what is rea what are these people
creating
uh
man this is this is a vague way to put
this maybe i can come back at this later
and be a little more clear do you guys
understand what i'm talking about people
that are like obsessed with the truth
you're also creating reality so if you
drop bombs on someone yeah you can speak
the truth i i killed a bunch of people
i'm not going to say that
that's not me
theoretical this crazy guy might say um
that was the truth he was speaking the
truth but he was also a violent evil
person so the truth isn't enough you
need to be good as well um but what i
mean now we're talking about war and
what's good in war what i mean is in the
u.s someone says i think our country
should be doing certain things and i say
why do you think that they say take a
look at this information this historical
record and what's happening right now
wouldn't you agree with me and i'd say
you make a really good point i don't
agree on that issue but maybe there's
something we can do the left says you're
racist you're a bigot um x y and z
really happened you should vote for me
on this policy because uh putin is you
know kidnapping babies or how about you
know the desert storm the woman who said
oh they're killing babies and all that
stuff they lie
to convince you to give them something
the problem with that is
if we're not in the service of function
of of meritocracy of
effectiveness
then
it's just ripping things apart things
are being destroyed yeah exactly if
somebody says i believe we should take
this action for fake reason there's a
good chance they're wrong about that
action there's a good chance it makes
everything worse if someone's got a
really good point to be made and they
give you the evidence for their
decisions you can say i understand and i
agree let's give it a shot yeah i mean
don't trust anyone who says that they're
willing to allow misinformation to
spread if it helps their agenda get
across but because at bottom what
they're saying is
i'm not sure if any of what i'm about to
tell you from my position is actually
true but i do want you to believe it see
winston churchill used to tell the
british that they were going to win the
war but he didn't know it was just
propaganda
and then your country there's some war
would you not use propaganda no no
there's a big difference between saying
ian if you give me ten dollars then i'll
go save a whale and then take your ten
bucks and go buy a beer with it there's
difference of lying and just creating
propaganda and me saying give me the ten
dollars i will save these whales and
then i try and fail there's a big
difference there oh that's a good point
right but we only knew found out after
the fact but general comes out and says
we are going to win it's like yeah
that's an opinion he's he's like he's
trying to boost rail that i get we're
gonna do it i think what if he knows
you're gonna lose anyways and he's just
doing that like i think this no but this
is the question is there ethical
misinformation like you think about a
kid who's about to die in a hospital and
they're terrified and asking you mom
doctor am i going to die and you hold
their hand yeah you're going to die no
like probably telling them you're going
to be fine and letting them pass away in
their sleep would be the ethical thing
to do
even if it's a lie i suppose
yeah i think um
you know we often talk about the nuance
in information censorship is a good one
there's such thing as good censorship uh
people say censorship is wrong it's
always wrong it's not true at all when
someone's posting like child abuse on
social media yeah censors should remove
that and the person who posts it
illegal stuff should be taken down
censorship can be good um lying can be
good like you said if there's a child
who's dying and no no good is served by
telling like making the child suffer by
freaking him out then maybe you know you
know the kids got an hour to live and
you're like don't worry you're going to
be everything's going to be fine your
parents are here everything's great and
then they pass away and it's calm and
peaceful they're not scared so like can
that be used on a mass scale though like
you were saying with winston churchill
like just propagating even even like you
know they use dehumanization of the
other forces because they'd have that
problem with people not pulling the
trigger if they think of that oh if you
went out and you're like telling the
truth um these people are just like you
if you sat down and had a chocolate bar
with them you could talk for hours and
have a beer and they're just like you
who's going to pull the trigger in that
war
it's a tough question oh yeah you got to
use propaganda yeah well this is i think
getting back to sort of the ethical
bedrock here of whether it's ever okay
to lie and looking at this example of a
child who's dying i think there's also
an argument to be made that you can
comfort the child without lying to them
you don't have to literally say you are
going to die or even in that instance
for example if you come from a religious
household you actually believe your
child is going to go to heaven and be
with jesus you tell them that you're
going to go to heaven and be with jesus
it doesn't require that you lie to them
necessarily and so i would say
when it comes to dealing with people on
a mass scale
if you're lying
you are doing something wrong that's
what i genuinely believe yeah i mean
look and i understand that's a
controversial position because there are
a lot of white lies that people accept
that you can't tell fundamentally i
believe that lying is never okay for any
reason so let's let's talk about war for
a second let's say you're going into war
you know for a fact you're gonna win and
you stand in front of all the troops and
be like we're going to win and everyone
cheers and then you win that's fine you
tell the truth let's say you're not
entirely sure it could go either way
but you're going to rally people and say
we will win
that's different right the idea is like
you have a fighting chance so long as
people believe then if you believe and
you and everyone's got morale boosted i
think it's fair to say you'll win i'm
okay with that if you know for a fact
you're going to lose
and there's limited purpose served and
you're just telling people to die wrong
no but there are times where they knew
they were going to lose and they said
we're going to stay and we're going to
win and then lightning strikes the enemy
camp and stuff like that has happened
well it's true that you don't know so
they stay hot there's a really important
point to be made here which is that
they're they're you get into an uh an
interesting ethical question
when you ask is it
lying to say something as if you know it
for sure when you don't i think that's a
lot more complicated i would argue that
telling your soldiers you are going to
win when there's a chance that you're
not going to win could actually
negatively affect your chances because
we're just going to win but if you tell
your soldiers this could go either way
you got to fight really hard to make
sure that we come out on top that could
be better for morale that's a good point
actually and and and you you would say
we're going to win so long as you put
everything behind it exactly this
depends on you don't falter yeah i think
that people perform better when they fee
when they think they're going to win
well people vote for the candidate i
think is going to win just because they
think they're going to win but like
wouldn't there okay so you look at like
the gallipoli campaign showing up on
those beaches and just seeing everyone
slaughtered around you and being told
like you know you're going to win you're
going to win this war and then wouldn't
that like rush doubts through your head
everything i've been told is a lie
everything
for this cause is this why winston
churchill sent us here to die yeah world
war ii like i don't know midway through
the war they decided to invade near
italy gallipoli that's part of turkey uh
and they they just beachheaded it and
landed and it was just a slaughter a
british and an australian annihilation
yeah devastation i think you got to be
honest
but this is this is the challenge um the
cheaters will lie and the cheaters get
that advantage
and so you got to hope that i think but
i think a lot of disadvantage yeah well
i would argue that in the long run lying
is a disadvantage because you end up in
such a tangled web of misinformation
that you're not making decisions based
on reality anymore it does catch up to
you it depends on what your goal is so
when you look at a lot of these
establishment players i feel like most
of their goals is just in individual
power self-interest yeah they want a
nice house for themselves like that blm
lady who owns like five houses or
whatever you know okay whatever you know
they come out and they claim they're
doing all these good things they lie
sure for humanity it sucks it's making
everything worse people burn down
buildings and die but the individual
succeeded in their plan lying helped
them they got what they wanted they
extracted what they could and then those
of us that say you know we gotta be as
honest as possible it's it's it's you
know i'll give you an example
um with the stories that are coming
around the ghost of kiev and snake
island what was i saying the other day
ian about the ghost of kiev i've not
seen any evidence it's a true story yeah
i've not seen i i've seen clips on the
internet of a plane of course i don't
know what that is it is a cool story
it's masculine it's a hero it's ace
fighter pilot so it's cool it boosts
morale but i don't know that it's true
now it turns out at least some of the
footage was not even real it was from a
video game and so people are like maybe
this is not real it's propaganda and it
probably is the case the same thing
happened with covington when that story
came out yeah people sent me this video
and i'm like it's some kid standing
there i have no idea what this is well
look at the kid's face i'm like what
about his face i don't and so i looked
and someone sent me a facebook live
stream show what happened and i was like
i don't understand the native american
dude walked up to him why are you mad
like people are mine are mindless
towards this stuff they just don't care
they want to believe it
the manipulation
i think with the covington kids really
ended up being very detrimental to media
organizations
but if your goal is just to maximize
your individual profits you don't care
how much damage you're causing to the
system or the country
honesty if you see a video of a jet
flying you'll be like i saw a jet flying
yesterday but no you didn't you saw a
video a bunch of pixels of some some
data you didn't see the jet and so when
we're in the metaverse and we're
experiencing reality what we think we're
seeing we sang was anyway i'm sorry it's
only one angle oh yeah no i just had a
thought that was like you know i was
thinking about your point you're like
people who lie will eventually lose and
i'm like maybe the reason that the lies
are necessary is because we've had a
cultural and moral decay whereas the
lies wouldn't be necessary without that
because you could just tell someone yeah
you know what you might die
but this is a cause worth dying for
whereas today you couldn't people are
like no i i don't want to fight unless
we're going to win like i was saying
about the border guards who don't care
about what's happening at the border yes
there's there's a video that got
released recently of a plane landing at
uh at an airport in i think um
uh what's what's the what's the
westchester is that north of new york i
think it was maybe but uh it lands north
of new york and there's a federal
contractor and there's a cop and he's
like what are you doing and they're like
i don't know we're supposed to do this
and he's like okay well you're not
supposed to but we're gonna let you do
it anyway and then the contractor says
to the cop no one can know we're doing
this and he's like why it's like because
the government's betrayed the american
people those are two guys
that don't care about this country at
all and one's a federal contractor and
wants a cop
that i think is is indicative of what's
happened to this country that you would
witness
a a serious crime by your government and
be like don't care it doesn't affect me
you know i think about these stories i
hear from you know morocco or brazil or
russia about bribing cops
and and they say it's like it's the norm
you're in south america and you get
pulled over slipping 50 bucks and you're
on your way right south african driver's
license it's just like is that what it's
all about they call it a driver's
license in any country you go to where
you can do that but in the united states
you can't do that you try bribing a cop
yeah you're gonna no one would even try
because they know the cops probably
gonna be like you can't afford me and
i'm not risking i got a body camera it's
never gonna happen but there is a
certain degree of of corruption that
we're starting to tolerate and that is
complete self-interest is it is it so
different a bribe right if i give you
cash versus if
you overlook a serious federal crime by
your government because you like the
money you're being given by them
yeah i think we've just got better pr
than a lot of the rest of the world yeah
american propaganda is the best in the
world let me let me tell you about where
this country's at how about that
this is gonna this one this is a a
segment for all of our socialist friends
out there we have the story from
barrons.com i love the name russia's
swift exclusion could spur cyber attacks
10 stocks that could benefit
that's an amazing headline if i've ever
seen it so let me break that down what
were you saying about uh moral decay
yeah yeah exactly swift is the
international payment system it's like
the society for worldwide what is it you
know international or something or
whatever oh yeah financial transactions
yeah there you go i don't know something
like that
and it's the banking system so they're
slowly kicking out russia's banks from
swift which i believe could result in
russia being unleashed they're already
sanctioned they're already in this
position and now you're saying we're
going to remove any leverage we have
over you outright just get rid of those
backing them into a corner
or unleashing them um letting them
letting them off the hook or letting
them off the leaf should ramp up what's
the quote a man with nothing left to
lose is a dangerous man yes
and so uh i believe you know i said this
before that i think banning russia from
swift would be a huge mistake because
you're effectively escalating the
conflict the most extreme way possible
russia's now got no ties to these other
countries or financial institutions so
if they nuke you it won't affect them
because you're now severed you severed
all those economic ties
well barron's excellent name by the way
is saying you can benefit by
well they're not saying you could
they're saying 10 stocks that could
benefit and they go on to list a bunch
of companies like hey you know you know
what they're saying they're basically
telling people without telling them
directly buy these stocks war is good
for profits
always a way to make money in the
markets i suppose and here i am trying
to figure out what stocks they're
telling me to buy talenteer oh of course
balance here
yeah they say palo alto networks
z-scaler crowdstrike tenable holdings
varana systems
fortinet telos mandiant palantir and
cyber arc software so is it ethical to
make money off the decline
i don't i why wouldn't it i don't even
know what the word ethics means anymore
can you define that for me
i mean
i mean
but i guess so many of that so much of
that has become an individual thing
rather than something we would all agree
on yeah there's sociological ethics and
then there's personal ethics there's a
good question though is it is it um
is it okay to profit off the decline of
the united states i i tweeted out that i
bought a bunch of uh
russian vodka the other day before they
banned it and people were like this is
really unethical of you to go get
embargoed products like you want to make
money off and i'm like oh you know what
it's not i can't do anything to stop it
i think that
as a society it's unethical not to
profit off of the decline of nature like
the destruction creation of nature if
we're not trying to profit off of it
then we're not doing our system justice
well what do you mean by the destruction
of nature and i guess also to find
profit oh what if what if the profiting
off it makes it worse like accelerates
well yeah definitely that's bad yeah i
guess i guess you know hold on a lot of
people are probably gonna say not true
rip off the band-aid or peel it slowly
yeah yeah you know uh
rip it off and rip it with the hair not
against the hair have you seen that meme
where it's like in the event of a
nuclear strike lay down face towards the
blast put your hands on your head that
way the the blast hits your head sooner
and you'll die faster oh my goodness
it's like a dark was it unethical for
them to tell kids to duck and cover in
the cold war get under your desk and
then the nuclear blast you'll you might
have some chance to survive which they
were though and they knew they wouldn't
that's the right oh yeah
depending on the distance oh actually
i see yeah the initial blast radius for
a lot of nuclear bombs is not it's not
as wide people think they think it's
like 30 miles it's like a half mile
maybe which is massive there's a there
was this thing i think the new york
times did where they showed an overlay
of different nuclear bombs and how it
would affect manhattan and it's like
yeah from river to river manhattan hit
is hit so if you're in if you're in
jersey city and manning gets hit by a
nuke you're not in the immediate blast
or radiation zone but you're going to
get by the shock wave so
you see the light you duck and cover
because glass oh yeah the shards are
going to go flying do you guys have a
bomb shelter
no he's ready
no uh but you know let's get the shovel
none of you have bombed on
zillow they were selling a uh
warhead like missile underground oh yes
station did you see that that was wild
well yeah but you could it was like 300k
yeah this will silence get a missile
silo so you could and they're they're
really deep and it's not even that
expensive like like you got to think
about buying a house these days the
prices are going up 300k what is it like
16 floors that's that's cheaper than a
townhouse go live in a missile silo i
think was it was it jake paul or like mr
beast they went to one of these
emergency shelter nuclear silos that'd
be fun and it's like you live
underground for 30 years in the event of
a nuclear strike or something but does
it come with the missile is the real
question i think they took the missile
because i think they took it how can you
still call it's just a silence
it's no longer a missile silo it's false
just an empty silo well i can tell you
this um i don't think it's wrong to
profit necessarily it depends on how you
look at it but i'll say
since all of this stuff has been
happening and getting crazier i've i've
certainly bought stuff that i think is
going to help me i've bought you know
we've got bug out kits we've gotten
emergency food that's just like i would
like to survive if bad stuff happens but
i've bought silver and gold yeah i've
bought bitcoin and bitcoin just went up
quite a bit
so as soon as they were talking about
banning russia from swift i was like i
better buy more bitcoin when i learned
about it well so so real quick because
if russia is kicked off of swift they're
going to have to replace their
international transactions with some
kind of infrastructure and bitcoin is is
essentially free infrastructure they
still have to build some russian
specific you know hubs and stuff so then
i thought why would they use anything
but bitcoin if they've already got a
bunch if it already exists and it's
already connected internationally you're
effectively telling them to go on this
decentralized shadow network instead of
the government-controlled one they're
gonna be like fine
i thought bitcoin's gonna skyrocket
because of this but more importantly i
don't wanna be holding us dollars yeah
let me just tell you man that beer you
got there old 690 it's a great place
gone prices oh yeah for sure they're
they're they're a local brewery and
their prices went up yeah and i noticed
like i i maybe we bought more i don't
know but it was more expensive than a
couple months ago when we bought it and
it's probably inflation yeah we we went
to go buy some whiskey from the liquor
store we get the good stuff the price
doubled that's the trifecta we've got
the pandemic we've got the russia phobia
of the cold war but now we got to get
the uh the economic crap 80s uh 80s gas
shortage and hyperinflation we got to
get the hyperinflation the wheelbarrows
and cash when i was it was 2678 when i
first learned about the military
economic order basically i was like well
i can't profit off this in good
conscience so i stopped making money
completely i was totally poor for like a
decade lived in abject almost not abject
poverty but pretty close to like living
in my car kind of poverty because i just
did not want to profit off the system
but it was to the point where i was
destroying myself like i couldn't
participate and help the system and i
realized if you want to untangle a ball
of yarn first you need to get a hold of
the ball of yarn i need to be rich to
fix this system from the inside
totally so i am profiting off this
unethical treatment of
slaves in uyghur china and things like
that
rich is probably the wrong word you need
you need to command influence yeah
that's true because the one of the
greatest things money gets you is
influence and that's what a lot of these
rich people want to do is buy a youtuber
and speak their words for them and
that's that's that's that's actually i
think a contradictory statement and
money doesn't buy you influence you can
try to buy influence but exactly michael
bloomberg he that guy dumped a lot of
money into this show he had a
diminishing return on his investment no
it's because his ideas are garbage
you know so he can he dumped what
happened half a billion dollars
so people were saying it was really
funny they were like tim you did a video
ragging on michael bloomberg and a
bloomberg yeah and i was like i would
like to thank michael bloomberg for
sponsoring a video where i rag on him
for 20 minutes we did a cartoon about
this when the bloomberg advertisements
were everywhere just ripping on the
bloomberg advertisements if you all want
to check that out and they were people
were commenting like oh i got a
bloomberg advertisement for this of
course because he's trying to counter
that messaging from you but it doesn't
work doesn't work no it makes my video
funnier yeah yeah so look there was a
there's a really funny story i read once
from buzzfeed uh maybe i shouldn't say
it's funny but there's this youtuber who
had 300k subscribers and was working as
a waitress and she said one day a little
girl was like oh my god you're so and so
why are you working as a waitress and
she was like oh i just you know it's a
job and then she went in the back and
cried because like she's famous but
broke and it's like yes you can have a
lot of influence and no money influence
is more valuable in a lot of ways and
depending on the type of influence
you're trying to do if you're trying to
threaten systems that do have more money
than you there is a cut-off point for
how influential you're going to be
because if you don't have any money to
fight back what these people are going
to do to you they will steamroll you the
rich can absolutely squash the poor in
anything
they'll you can get this is why the
press focus on youtubers when they
slander people you know you'll have
someone um oh
who's the guy from braveheart i can't
remember
mel gibson thank you
this beer hit hard
um you'll literally call jews oven
dodgers and you'll get plenty of
articles from mainstream media that are
like mel gibson on a fancy vacation at
this show at that show uh but a youtuber
will say one off-color word like they'll
say read once or something and that'll
get a whole article in all these
different outlets they'll only be
referred to as extremist right wing this
that because they know they can get away
with it because mel gibson can afford
massive amounts of lawyers yeah
representative whereas youtubers don't
really have that i think i think we've
got um with kyle renton houses you know
he's going to do this he's got he's
going to be bankrolling no no for sure
for sure but i'm saying him and project
veritas i think are going to help change
that game but they're still they've
they've hit that threshold of the amount
of money you have to have to be able to
fight back against the elites because if
you if you if you are just small if
you're someone i mean tommy robinson had
money but you can just send someone to
jail that's just fantastic
yeah you can't afford a lawyer if they
know you're threatening the idea is to
change the system without them realizing
that it's
like uber appeared and it was a threat
to the taxi system but they didn't
realize it till uber was prevalent i
just think people got to see wikipedia i
would love to do that but every lawyer
has said not possible so we talked about
that a little bit yeah we talked about a
little bit before the show cause i said
this to james o'keefe as well
i said sue wikipedia the organization
directly and the issue everyone says is
oh but it's user generated content no
it's not well then why does every lawyer
tell me that it's there because they
haven't gone to the website
if there is a lawyer watching this that
can sue wikipedia with me send me an
email so you guys are saying before the
show you're saying on wikipedia you go
to the article sorry yeah and then
there's a byline and the byline says
from wikipedia so they're basically
claiming they are the author of this
story and uh yeah so uh we have this
story from wikipedia
lauren is it is cherie shuri
is a canadian alt-right political
activist and white white nationalist and
youtuber lauren are you all right i'm
not alt-right and i'm not a white
nationalist but
they and you know in an article with a
living person you have to at least after
this put someone's rejection of a label
and they just won't even do that and
that's in their own like terms of you
know how the website should function
they just don't care well so here's the
issue right um you can see they've got
weird the interesting the sources here
for alt-right and they're it's an a and
a b
oh and you're not supposed to use
opinion pieces for like hardcore claims
that could hurt someone's reputation but
they do it anyway here's the funny thing
on my wikipedia they don't
they've actually rejected a bunch of
op-eds that were too over the top bro i
don't know how you got away with that
because he knows wikipedia can be sued
lauren because i keeps well so so with
the articles about me there was one um
this is really interesting it said tim
poole has donated to multiple
republicans and then someone in the talk
section said if you look at if you
actually search federal records tim pool
has donated to more democrats than
republicans
sure you can say he's donated to because
it's like i think it's like rand paul
but it's about what's left out of the
story that matters exactly and so but
then the editors were like i don't think
this is an accurate piece if they're
omitting something like this and so they
rejected it outright yeah i always look
at this and they could you know i would
consider myself a documentary filmmaker
you wouldn't even know i made
documentaries if you read my wikipedia
page and that's the what i've gotten the
most views for is my films that i've
made and you wouldn't even know reading
this well so here's the point we're
bringing up with lawsuits
this is what i said to james o'keefe it
says on
wikipedia.com.org sorry lauren southern
from wikipedia the free encyclopedia so
you know
there are some serious questions that
need to be answered by many different
courts from many different countries it
may be that i'm wrong and the court
decides that if a new if a media outlet
includes a byline of their own corporate
name
but
commenters provided the information for
the formation of that article you can't
sue them i would love a judge to pass
that precedent and then just watch the
absolute psychotic chaos that would
unfold on the internet so right now is
what you need to understand about
wikipedia first i'll i'll present it to
you like this
if um
sheamus over here freedom tunes coughlin
yeah over here posts on twitter
that lauren southern is you know a big
stupid dude she's saying it's true
lauren southern did a backflip a
statement of fact and that causes you
damages because you have a vow of no
backflips uh well you can't sue twitter
because the post says at jameis coughlin
yeah but what if it said at twitter on
it
you could sue twitter right
i mean of course of course the premise
makes sense but i've never seen anyone
do it what i have seen people do is so
it's the whole what's a publisher what's
a platform what is that section 230 that
covers this in the states yeah um and
people
in australia they've sued
uh google because google they choose
what articles you see they are
they're a publisher
they publish things and they use
wikipedia as their main source it
literally comes up in a separate sidebar
like if you look up on google lauren
southern they feature that and publish
that so you can sue google for this
because that's what they publish and
it's been successful in the courts
before really yeah well here's what i'm
saying the so when we had james here i
mentioned this and he was like yeah but
you know section 230 and i'm like yo the
byline on this wikipedia article is
wikipedia no one else so imagine this
imagine at timcast.com i tell people hey
if you comment we'll take all your
comments and then post it as a
legitimate news article could you
imagine if it said you know timcast.com
article byline tim poole and then it
said you know a political high-profile
political individual took action you
know i did something that was clearly
false like you know uh nancy pelosi
punches baby in face and then like
clearly defamatory clearly uh libelous
clearly slander but well you can't sue
me but does the language matter here
because it says from
wikipedia not by wikipedia and then
it'll tell you these specific editors
who i would love a judge to answer that
question yeah because if a judge says
well you know
that doesn't really count then i'll be
like
then i would love a judge to explain
how you can have an article it says
article on the article with a headline
lauren southern with a byline below it
and now the organization that published
it is exempt oh wait
whoa i'm reading something on here it
says i was demonetized by youtube and
banned from paypal i've never been
banned from paypal i use paypal every
day
and i'm not demonetized on youtube so
this is that's a false statement that's
not even true what are they referring
you know it when i was living in
australia my wikipedia said i was
permanently banned from australia they
can literally just make [ __ ] up it's
wild but so so so the issue is it needs
to be tested in the courts and we need
this i don't know if it'll go to the
supreme court or where it would end but
a judge needs to answer for how this
applies section 230 because wikipedia
does a lot here's another thing you see
that lock symbol next to your name yeah
that means it is not open to the public
interesting the lock means only specific
wikipedia individuals i have no idea how
to access that right i would have no
idea how to edit your page as a member
of the public okay so here's another
this is a whole on conspiracy world that
i'm going to get into there's an editor
on my page uh it seems like gray
something and
he
all day every day is sitting there
editing like michael malus page jack
posovic's page cernovich all of these
big right-wing figures i swear he's
being
paid by some sort of organization to do
this
like i genuinely believe there are
people being paid to edit wikipedia
articles and oh
i would be shocked if there weren't no
no no i i i know them you do okay so i'm
not crazy because i was like this guy
how is he sitting all day on wikipedia
just fighting in the comments section
they're called reputation management
firms yes yeah i tried to change hillary
clinton's wikipedia after the emails
dropped and talk about sydney blumenthal
and osprey global solutions and within
like 30 seconds it was removed within
like six years and they're just sitting
there monitoring it because they're
getting paid to do this and you're right
they've done reputation firms well
they'll create fake articles and put
those
i actually actually know people who do
this um i've actually
had uh events put on so i did an event a
while back with a buddy of mine and one
of the sponsors of the event was a
reputation management firm they they
they uh
here's how it was explained to me they
were like
you ever have the media lie about you
okay well here's what we'll do
we will get placement in several medium
tier blogs of stories and then we know
how to work seo to make sure they appear
on the top of google and then make them
more prominent then we'll go in and
we'll we'll have our employees argue on
wikipedia against the inclusion of
defamatory content yes now of course
these guys didn't say to me like we're
gonna lie and cheat and smear people to
ruin their lives they said the opposite
they were like the media writes fake
stories we protect you from that that
was that's that's how they frame it now
it may be the people i know actually are
you know doing the right thing but there
are people who do the wrong thing yeah
what that's what i was going to say is
what's scary is that obviously can be
used in the reverse the media are
writing accurate articles about you and
you're having
the wealthy can pay i i did a video on
this called sainthood for sale you can
literally pay for your reputation and if
you can't afford your reputation if
you're if you're a 19 year old kid or
even a high schooler that just gets
slandered in a local paper as a racist
and you don't have anything else online
about you and that's the first thing
that comes up your job options are
limited in the future you're screwed
over and you're not going to have money
for a lawyer you're not even going to
know the first thing what to do
whereas if you're extremely wealthy i
actually buy sainthood i i think
actually there's something interesting
here with the uh your wikipedia
there's a question over
i think the question of whether you can
see them has to do with whether or not
they're making opinion statements
that you know um but i think if
wikipedia
actually says something happened to you
that isn't true i think it's clear-cut
lawsuit for wikipedia so they they have
the biography don't you have to prove
malice in america um
yes you have to prove
that uh so actual malice is not like
hatred it means
that either
they knew it was false
or they were reckless as to the
publication of the information reckless
i'd say that yeah well so there's an
interesting thing here that wikipedia
might win the suit on the on the
question of malice and be like
we didn't know this person was doing
this we'll ban them instantly you know
and then that's all that can ever really
be done i don't know for sure i think it
needs to be i also really want to
clarify the public because people say
this all the time they're like oh well
if it's untrue just sue them any lawyer
you go to about defamation they'll
initially say to you all right hundred
thousand dollar down payment and there's
like a five percent chance we'll win
like that's right and then you have to
pay
all throughout the years like do you
think people oh just sue them no the
media can get away with so much faith
real quick though lauren i'm pretty sure
if you if you started a give send go to
he's going to bring up to just hire you
know lawyers and and do these suits i'm
pretty sure you'd make this is what
terrifies me and you should do that
we'll go into this in a second but
that's why justin trudeau calling up the
emergency acts and slamming down on the
crowdfunding is like that was i was
always like well at least you can
crowdfund it well if we want to buy
public property and turn into a private
property turn to a public park at least
we can crowdfund it which which is why
money doesn't always buy you influence
but if you have influence you can often
get money so i i don't i don't know your
financial background i don't think
you're you're a millionaire or a
billionaire lawyer i don't i don't know
totally yeah
here's my point though people people
people know you well enough they they
like you enough that if you said this is
defamatory slanderous
not only is it to um i mean
damages might be a challenge in a
lawsuit what damages have you incurred
due to them calling you white
nationalists there could maybe be an
argument for um you know familial
emotional i don't know i'm not a lawyer
so that could be tough but my point is
if you said hey i'm going to sue
wikipedia and i need help people will
help you and you know
that's influence yeah it's from i've
spoken to lawyers and you know even pro
bono lawyers that i've spoken to they're
just like it's so
hard like very very few people are
successful the only successes like i
said have been on google i haven't found
a single successful wikipedia lawsuit
maybe there's like one but he like
bankrolled absolute crap gotta try i
would imagine that's hard like not only
does it mean expensive but it takes a
long time oh yeah they just want to make
your life yeah you're 20. they will
torment you to make sure you don't set a
precedent
torment just keep you in the legal
system for a decade if they can and
i've never seen it be partly because i
don't like involving the legal system
unless it's absolutely last
you know the last year shot ready yeah
we're going to wide shot ladies and
gentlemen are you prepared for this
we're just getting ready for now
because we're gonna see what's gonna
happen so
thank you i don't remember what was i
talking about what's the wide shot i
have no idea something's happening
something something says
i'm sure everybody already knows in the
audience oh no so we i don't i don't i
don't know we're getting the camera not
running on the joke roll
oh
should we talk about it then yeah we can
talk about it but you were told they're
coming up i was told we were swatted
again yeah again are you serious oh i
should put this down
maybe we can talk to him on camera do
you no it's gonna pull the white camera
up anybody who wants to walk in here is
gonna be on on they're gonna be on live
yeah do you think they would be
interested well i guess that's when he
comes in
he's busy he's on duty so maybe not
right serious you're gonna swat it again
yeah third time three times a charm i
guess they know that that's been
happening so they're ready for it now
but i don't understand why they're
coming up and coming in they do a basic
check now because they know us
and it was like it was big news in there
you can't get it
no give me the why so they're gonna
actually come in here i didn't i i've
watched this on twitter i can't believe
i'm gonna come into this room yeah it's
correct okay yeah so they'll be visiting
us again just to make sure no one's
getting choked you know they're doing
their job maybe you should push that off
there's like there's like a table
so so i will say this
i used to have a mall sword behind me
it's a mall sword i went to a game store
and it's like some anime sword i don't
know what it is and i was like it was
like 20 bucks so i bought it and then
everyone's like what a dumb anime sword
like what a dumb mall sword and so i
actually ordered a wakazashi it is
people are like you've got it upside
down you're doing it wrong it's it's
it's it's dull it's not it's it's an or
it's ornamental it's beautiful calm down
no matter what i do people are like your
swords are bad welcome to the internet i
love that um
are they coming up what's that that's
what i want to see what happens
anticipation it might happen during the
super chats well i guess we're just
we're just chilling and it's a wild
night man
2020 is crazy you know this is uh so the
first time we got swatted it was right
after marjorie taylor green
and that was the
that was probably the worst one because
it was it was the first so the cops like
we had ton of cops he was crazy and uh
they came up the door open it was a cop
there and he's like fanning for me to
come like we like we're live in the
middle of a show like i'm not getting up
and these cops are peeking in i didn't
the cop walks in looks around and i'm
like what is going on luke was here and
he just keeps talking like then he
watches the cop leave so then once i
figured out what had happened and i got
the message saying like we were swatted
i was like okay then i got up and ran
out and said what happened they told us
that was um that was the day after
marjorie taylor green was here she was
here on january 5th yeah and so what i
think happened was
the show goes live
at 8 p.m on january 5th
it wraps up on youtube at 10 p.m on
january 5th that means most people won't
get the notification for it until
january 6 of all days to have marjorie
taylor green
so then
somebody swaps us
the next time it happened i think it was
the day after we had andy no yeah and
james james
did you ever find who was doing it
uh
uh
top men are on it top all right and
there's a thing swatting is not a joke
swatting is a terroristic activity
you're you're putting cops in heart and
potential harm's way you're putting
people in potential animals in harm's
way people can get killed it's not a oh
dude i literally just had like a nervous
like yeah my gun's on fire i'm like what
if a cop walked in and i was literally
holding that sword yeah i'm i was
actually like
gonna process it
that way
this person is a terrorist whoever made
that phone call as a terrorist is a
domestic terrorist and they might not be
american but they're a terrorist i
didn't i didn't you know so i didn't
want to bring it up that it happened you
know so like lydia's like messaging me
and i'm just like i'm just gonna i was
wondering what you two were on about
yeah i was like
like technically it looks good then when
we heard that they were coming up i'm
like okay well better you have to say
something now we better say otherwise
you know it's gonna abruptly happen so
i'm i'm trying to verify exactly what's
going on i'm messaging people yeah i'm
curious what happens i guess we'll just
have to wait i think the second time
they came by they didn't come up here
yeah talk to people downstairs and then
left yeah they did like a suite but they
weren't on the show they know what this
is and here i'll tell you what really
bothered me about the first time it
happened was um
when they came here they said it was
accident circumstances they have a right
to enter the property
but uh they also said on the radio we
think this is a it's a swatting because
it's a political podcast which means
they outright lost exogenous
circumstances right away by thinking
that they have to they have to believe
that there is something happening to
they can violate our fourth amendment
rights i'm not a fan of that like i can
respect them coming and rushing into
danger and all that stuff and being like
but if they genuinely think it's a
swatting like why are you here dude yeah
yeah
but i'll say this it's i guess it's good
that they keep coming yeah well can't
they just like check the stream and be
like oh okay nothing look who they have
they probably do probably but there's so
many employees in the house that it's
yeah i have no idea but that's why i'm
like i can't believe they're actually
going to come up
right i'm glad they do i'd rather they
check on us
i suppose give them a little high five
this is all like a hostage situation and
we all just have
on good terms you can be with a cop is
in a moment when you're being swatted
like they're so much on your side at
that point because they think something
bad is happening to you yeah it's
important to keep in mind if something
like that happens
oh
we think this is a first so yeah me too
as well disappointing what did you guys
think about that well it was uh it was
interesting it's not over yet i want to
make light of it but it's such a bad
reward i agree it's a horrible thing to
do just a dangerous devilish terrible
thing to do to a human is this using
agree but we're at war you know or maybe
we're not we have been war since world
war ii but the world is in some sort of
psychological conflict so i understand
why i'm just telling you that it is very
bad very dangerous and don't do it again
well
thanks for coming lauren
thanks for almost getting me killed guys
i'm not in on the joke oh lauren's
holding the sword
nice play it wasn't a joke maybe maybe
that's why you know we'll uh we'll have
a we'll get a little red light it says
like swatting on it yeah
good idea to be honest if you walk
through the other everyone put the
weapons down if you walk
he'd probably be like nice sword and
look around and make sure no one's
getting hurt and then walk out
so i i don't think they're coming in
okay i think they're being told not to
and they're like okay okay so they're
actually listening come say hi hang on
shut up dude they want to be on the show
so he can be like confirmed yeah man
pop in that'd be fun uh so you know
we'll get to super chats smash the like
button if you like the show we'll do
super chats in the seconds
so they're they're they're meeting with
them outside yeah they're andy's talking
to him same people same guys probably
all right well there we go
putin did it someone said in chat and
putin did it putin did it
i think it wasn't true like putin is
sitting watching the show and he's like
betty i just can't take it anymore i
gotta get these guys yeah all right so i
think we're good i think we're good
that's why i was like i didn't want to
say anything because if they if they
don't come up i'm like we're just not
gonna bring it up if it happens but i
was told they would be coming up i guess
maybe they were dissuaded
okay all right then well if the door
opens and cops walk in then we will have
it that's why but uh we'll uh we'll do
uh super chats then so we'll take your
audience questions smash that like
button subscribe the channel share the
show with your friends go over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have that members-only segment coming up
for you around 11 or so p.m
let's see what we got here
all right
let's see let's find a good super chip
rob matt says if the if nukes were
dropped will you continue doing the show
how can we listen if the internet goes
out some type of radio broadcast maybe
we all need a voice if that happens
uh you know i've been who's the guy from
fallout 3
the guy from fallout yeah like the radio
host yeah the radio guy i don't remember
he's cool though yeah the radio host
from fallout 3. you play fallout 3 right
awful i think i stopped it too what's up
two was good really
stopped having time for video games
someone super chat the name
i'm waiting for someone to chat the name
of the the radio host from fallout three
dog i thought it was three dog i thought
it was three dog but i've been playing
three dog night too much i was like am i
just thinking of the band
yeah free dog post apocalyptia that's
what we're going to be doing we're going
to get like a ham radio and we should
probably get a ham radio yeah
not because nuclear war just for fun but
we should do it
all right
raymond g stanley jr says shim cass with
the best wooden sun thank you very much
i appreciate that yeah
all right
here we go what is let's grab a good
super chat you always got to go throw
them three dog everyone's saying three
dog that's right it is three doug
james rogers says respectfully i don't
believe russia having nukes on high
alert is that big of a deal countries in
wartime scenarios often do that as a
deterrence and if putin believes ukraine
is his i doubt he'd nuke his own country
i don't think he's gonna nuke ukraine i
think he's going to nude someone else
yeah
you know i normally wouldn't think it's
a big deal either but you know i i
didn't think that there were actually
going to be boots on the ground in
ukraine so now i'm like i don't trust
anything i think
like two days before it happened we had
uh you know we had steve renae on and
he's you know he spent time in belarus
he's he was an intelligence guy and was
he was army right special forces i think
and he was just like
that you know they might go into the
east and i said do you think they'll go
as far west as kharkiv and he's like no
and i was like they're they're saying
that they're going to march they're
going to come north from belarus into
kiev because it's insane he's like yeah
that won't happen i'm like i agree and
then
yeah and it happened and lots of people
in like i had friends that were in
ukraine um like on the ground there and
they're like no no one here thinks
there's going to be an invasion right
right the whole narrative was like
ukrainians were living their lives
saying like even was it wasn't zelinski
like there's no war telling the
mainstream media in america to calm down
like chill it so clearly you know u.s
intelligence had some good sources just
there was so much there were like the
sun published there was going to be an
invasion at 3 a.m the week before it
happened
and that's what really brought my doubts
in because there's been so it's like the
boy who cried wolf and you can see
articles for the last 10 years invasion
of asian invasion but the problem with
the story the boy who cried wolf is
there actually was a wolf eventually
yeah exactly and it eats them yep yeah
but no one believes at that point so it
is a huge problem with the media that we
can't believe anything they tell us or
you just find media sources that are
better like alex jones
clearly he's got some good intel too
yeah
if you listen alex jones he said in
february war was coming so i want you to
imagine this somebody's sitting there
listening to alex jones back in october
and alex is like listen people you know
there's going to be a big war in
february like world war one world war ii
that kind of stuff and the guy goes
i'm gonna buy a bunch of bitcoin um i'm
gonna buy some emergency food and now
with like inflation and prices going up
all this is going down and he's like i'm
good don't gotta run to the store don't
gotta wait in line imagine if a russian
person you see all the lines at the atms
because of the ruble getting hit
imagine someone in russia was like hey
looks jones good guys funny show
i'm going to get out cash because of war
you know and now now they're fine and i
just got to say look the media can rag
on alex all day and night and he said
some crazy stuff like on joe rogan's
show about cell towers and human animal
hybrids and other weird stuff that
scares me how right he's been i'm like i
wonder i just this is it's complex
enough i don't need that my favorite my
favorite meme was like it's like i used
to think alex jones was a crazy
conspiracy theorist now if he comes out
tells me werewolves are invading i'm
gonna go buy silver
[Laughter]
but what's like
you know to be fair you throw a bucket
of spaghetti
yeah you know what i mean but um
uh
but when it sticks in really interesting
patterns you're like whoa is this magic
spaghetti or maybe someone planted glue
no but uh
um you know i i reached out to alex
and you know basically what he said was
watch the episode he did because people
are wondering how he knew he explains it
all in great detail the clip everyone's
posting is just a short clip where he's
like war in february but he actually
breaks down what he thinks is going to
happen and he's like i think he said it
wasn't an exact prediction you know if
you get the full context you'll see that
it's just like a half prediction that he
got you know what i mean but we made the
jar downstairs says alex jones was right
jar yeah i think we should have like a
little jar up like on a shelf and then
whenever we like we'll have someone who
just covers what alex says and if he's
right we'll be like all right five bucks
in the jar and we'll get up and we'll
put it in yep it's but you know i
suppose the funny thing is though it's
because like the media says he's wrong
and he's crazy so often that when he's
right you're like it's an f you to the
media that he got something right
all right elizabeth carmella says
sheamus boy if i missed you in my
opinion you'd break you bring out the
best in tim some of that back and forth
between you two is the best i agree he's
miserable without me
i think the best back and forth is when
i voice dr fauxxy on friday look it's
not bad and you know we have some uh
fouchy freedom tune stuff that's gonna
be coming out donor exclusives
won't give me any other roles he gave me
like the voice of cop once you do a good
alex jones yeah look at that i don't but
it's not it's not as good as mine not
that i'm going to do it right now or
anything
i thought you were no you're going full
alex jones
no ian i won't let you you're supposed
to peer pressure me into this pressure
so uh the the joke we have for the vlog
is that we are going to have it be that
tim cass is completely funded based off
voice voice over royalties from freedom
too that's actually true though yeah
that's true yeah short form card
sheamus has never paid me a a single
penny
for all of the hard work why would you
say that
that's not true he's like you're
exploiting my labor that's actually true
i'm living off of this i'm living off of
the surplus value of tim's labor he
needs to rise up
that's the example of capital without
money
there you go booyah all right storm says
what stories are we missing out due to
this conflict i'm not saying a conflict
has started to cover it up just stuff
can't uh but uh to cover up stuff but
you can't let a good crisis go to waste
can't wait to watch a bit later
it's a good question
um the trucker convoy's happening
they're i think passing through missouri
joplin i think there's pass through they
get here on the fifth or in in dc rather
is it that is it the fifth that's what i
read on the internet they're gonna be in
hagers it must not be true
oh yeah oh interesting let's question it
yeah there's already military trucks
parked out in dc yeah they're worried
about oh they i was at the um capital
today and they had built up all of these
fences and barriers because everyone
wanted to go in and hug joe biden so
badly oh yeah so the you know most
popular president ever they got a well
look block it off i certainly understand
what joe must be going through everyone
always trying to hug me yeah
some sense
joe man it's kind of crazy what's
it it's it's the nation's capital it's
like the people should be allowed to go
they they they used to
you could walk into the congressional
building and walk around there's there's
there's old photos from back in the day
where you could walk on the lawn of the
white house
it's already like maybe we don't need a
capital that that we can all work online
and then if we want to go to and get
together for congress it can just be any
city at any time they can pick a
difference yeah but bro then someone
will deep fake a congress person
you know in person you got to be helped
to be in person
yeah because you talk about remote
voting and stuff like that and it's like
they could go they could use zoom it's
like i've seen that tom cruise video
where the guy they do the digital
editing so he looks like tom cruise i
saw that that audio where they they
ai programmed joe rogan's voice
and jordan peterson
and then the scary thing is like what if
what if jordan peterson promised to do
like an online seminar that was audio
only and it was just sheamus the whole
time i was like well actually i wouldn't
even need an ai to do that i would just
go like this
what if what did the ai have jordan
peterson say what you know would be
really scary what if jordan peterson
actually said all those things and they
just told us it was an ai what would be
funny if like an ai
was being fed a script of jordan
peterson and it becomes sentient because
of peterson's like speeches oh i've made
my room no here's what i think is
happening
dive with me down this conspiracy theory
rabbit hole that i'm formulating right
now so all of the celebrities and public
figures in the world have gotten
together to convince us that deep fakes
exist so that when they get caught on
video doing bad things they could go oh
that's just a deep fake true controlled
opposition look at that what if sheamus
was jordan peterson the whole time i
have been and jordan
why won't he come on the show it's
because he's been here the whole time i
haven't been here exactly has anyone
ever seen dc has anyone seen sheamus and
jordan peterson in the same room yes
that was scripted that's true yep i feel
like when he gets older he'll look like
i'll look a little jordan peters and
they have similar frames look at they
have the same structure it's because we
have an archetypal hero structure right
it's just how we look
as a matter of fact very high quality
high status men who reach the top of the
dominance hierarchy tend to appear
similarly correct all right iv says tim
i am a dot com member sub and i've super
chatted numerous times and you have yet
to read my super chat i got you now
buddy no
would you please invite tor muras on the
show torey morass how do you pronounce
it even better if posobik was on with
her we will look into
uh t.o.r.e morass you know that is we'll
look this person up i do not know who
this person is
edward mcclung says hey tim love your
show but you need to turn your katana
edge up you're damaging it it's a
wakazashi i got you ha ha you think
you're going to tell me and it's also
ornament
well it's actually real it's just not
sharpened i don't i did not want an
actual
sharpened blade because i knew i was
going to put it up i mean debates get
too heated yeah do you consider like
where you place your guests like oh i
don't want to put this like big lefty
guest near the katana
they wouldn't know how to use it no all
of the uh uh like the the scheduled
guests sit where you're sitting yeah you
have like a little orange thing and then
you've got a little because because he's
got a little button he can press it
we'll never mind oh but i i did get a
sword this time so you could set me up
but the cops decided to come out
you grabbed the sword
started swinging it around it was crazy
maniac
let's grab ah let's grab another
thought-provoking super chat
yeah you guys super chats are awesome
let's see ben says the united states is
currently buying 20 million dollars
worth of oil from russia every day
i think that's a that's interesting and
now they're getting like five gallons
for that but
all right
ready to rumble says tim has no idea
what he's talking about when it comes to
russia probably doesn't even realize
that half the ukrainian army are nazis
um
i watch vice
i've known about the uh like the the
nazi battalion are they the azov or
something yeah or whatever it's like yes
does that mean that they should not be
allowed to have borders and like russia
should be allowed to go in there because
they're nazis like i said left argument
this is a leftist who's arguing that if
there's a country with nazis they should
be invaded by another country and those
like i don't know actually putin said
that he was invading because you want to
get rid of the neon
that's very woke
well i i think their argument also it
like they're playing on um
russia was diametrically opposed to the
nazis at least at the end of world war
ii right so they're kind of bringing
that back from a lot of the people who
um
would remember that attitude they did an
american pride they were like
punch-a-nots they didn't punch a nazi
campaign like don't punch anybody what
the heck don't just pick a group of
people you didn't that were used to be
evil and demonize well it's the issue
isn't punch a nazi so much as it is
punch anyone i call a nazi and i'm going
to call everyone a nazi yeah you ever
see that song by chris raygun yeah but
he got scared and he deleted it
oh did he yeah he deleted it but it
still exists because it's a really good
song there were so many people that made
like good funny anti-woke content that
have deleted so much of it like h3h3 and
idubbbz used to make really funny stuff
and they got scared yeah they got i
swear they got scared and then h3h3
really went towards like what is just
gonna get me
popular and keep me online i don't know
about in my opinion i i would i would
try and be um a bit more that's the
right word um charitable charitable i
think it's an issue if they're terrified
of losing their jobs yeah i think that's
fair too maybe yeah maybe i'm just not
being well so you can see what happened
to that freedom tunes guy man he used to
make these jokes dragon on the left just
became a complete
of the road lefty type
authoritarian tunes yeah exactly i will
it's biden tunes now
and we make providing cartoons i think
about it this way there's a lot of
people who say that they're unwilling to
speak up because they want to lose their
jobs right yep well look at people like
chris ray gun or
h3h3 or um
who was it hunter avalon you know
he he we had him on the show i think he
quit did like he like quit recently yeah
it's actually like i don't care what
someone's ideology is he genuinely was
just seems like he was having a bit of a
mental breakdown from the internet
attention stuff which happens to like
every creator at some point so i i hope
he's doing all right i think when you
lack when you lack mental fortitude and
you're put in a position of um high
visibility
you're very prone to having that kind of
breakdown
because for a lot of people they can't
withstand
someone saying bad things about them you
know even you know james o'keefe talked
about this that early on in his career
he would see these posts made about in
these stories and they were wrong and it
would like hurt him and he would be like
i don't understand why they're saying
these awful things about me and like
it's not true and you want people he
wants people to know and then eventually
got older and he was like it it whatever
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna be true to
myself and just do my thing
i've i've always been
just me personally to like arrogant i
guess so when someone insults me i'm
like i'm i'm better than you so screw
you you know what i mean so for me i
don't care if i lose my job i don't i'm
going to say what i want to say
and
that's very helpful in media
but i think it works right but then you
have the interesting thing was you know
chris raygun produced a lot of he's not
he's not a political guy would he come
on the show if you asked him no i really
really because really bad stage right oh
okay
oh i don't know about that question but
i doubt he would
because i feel like there was a period
where like i've known him we hung out
with him
um he was like anti-state w because
they're authoritarians but him getting
rid of the punch of nazi video was
really interesting because a leftist
made an argument that it helped nazis or
something and so he was like oh okay so
we unlisted it it was so well done too
it was he's got talent it was really on
point it was like yeah it was like
making fun of the idea that everyone's a
nazi and this guy is insane and in a
cult
but i think what happens is a hunter
avalon is a good example he was a dude
who produced a bunch of anti-sw content
on youtube and then one day he's like
hey i'm a liberal now and i think what
really happened is he saw what was
happening to all these different
youtubers who are getting banned and
it's like look if you've got hundreds of
thousands of subs and you're making six
figures and you don't know what career
you would do after this
not only that if let's say like
i i can't i can't use myself in this in
this in this analogy but for a lot of
these people who they only have one
channel and they're they're like they
found their their their
voice or whatever if they got banned and
were known as a nazi they'd freak out
because you'll never get a job anywhere
absolutely you'll you'll apply
mcdonald's and they'll be like i don't
know man i looked you up on the internet
and maybe you shouldn't work here and so
they freak out and they're like just
tell me what to say me i'm like i'll go
live buck naked in the woods screw you
so we're gonna i'm gonna say i know
people who work at anti-extremist
organizations that are completely
right-wing privately
wow and so they
you said coward wrong yeah oh yeah
but it's like they they're in that
position where it's like i'll never get
a job i'll never be able to feed my
family and of course it's when i say
anti-extremist i don't actually i mean
people have confused anti-extremism with
just converting someone to the left yep
like you're an extremist if you're a
conservative so to not be an extremist
you have to be left-wing even if i'm a
left-wing or advocating for bombing
pipelines or something that's not an
extremist then right um so i've kind of
referred to like these anti-extremist
orgs as just
uh nazi job recruiting offices because
no one does a political 180.
no one it doesn't happen it makes no
sense no
it's it's the most but but but look even
for people on the right i mean
like
dave rubin made a very dramatic switch
and a lot of people were were very
critical of it and uh he he got uh uh
well i don't describe it controversy
when he went on joe rogan and he was
talking about building codes and stuff
and people were like you know even joe
was like what are you talking about with
building codes like what is your
position on this and that's what even
dave's been heavily criticized for his
his you know
hard switch candace owens has been
criticized for this they said that she
was like boxing people i don't know a
lot about the history like i don't know
what dave was doing before i don't know
what candace was doing before
um and honestly i think there's
something something to be said for
somebody who goes from being in the
popular
establishment side to the dangerous risk
of getting banned side you know what i
mean you just shake yourself out of the
military industrial complex quell that
it's put you under we're under the spell
we're born into it told it's normal to
be at war like shake out of it it
doesn't mean you have to go politically
haywire just
become self-aware
are you just like hilarious saying that
surrounded by your abacus and all these
horrors that's why i have all this stuff
man like we gotta break the spell man
it's a joke
let's read some more super chats we have
make 1984 fiction again and um before i
read the super chat i'm going to mention
we have a t-shirt at timcast.com store
and it says join the city urban liberal
types and the first letter of each of
those words is red so it says join the
cult
make 1984 fiction again says city urban
neoliberal types
uh i like it i really like it i'm not
going to say that one but uh you get
that neoliberal is one word yeah liberal
is one word there you go
all right let's see
what is this jgj's thoughts on marjorie
taylor green's association with a young
idiots conference saw the eric erickson
clip that was posted i don't know that's
a reference to are you referring to the
america first conference
if you are because i don't know if you
mean young idiot by that but um marjorie
taylor green spoke at nick fontes's
thing and the media was like why are you
speaking at a white nationalist
conference and she was like i was
speaking to people at a conference to
tell them about ideas i believed in or
something like that and i'm just like
these journalists it's really funny to
hear them yelling that because they have
no idea what they're talking about it's
like i don't i don't know or care look
she said i disavow white nationalism i
was speaking to people who cared about
america
but the journalists were all like what
but it's a white nationalist conference
and it's like
okay i guess if you say so how what is
that you're not even asking me a
question you're just saying a thing over
and over again sure white nationalism is
stupid i get it marjory taylor green has
opinions
question her opinions and ask her
something about it what is white
nationalism i mean i'll ask this from
time to time because definitions change
from time to time so what is it today
well wikipedia has dubbed me the expert
i'm glad you're here maybe you can help
me
it's simple i think it means you have
borders
the actual uh white nationalism is
people who believe that there should be
a country just for white people so it's
like racial society that's like the real
definition that's right the real
definition of course so when they come
out and they and and they're accusing
you
what they're trying to claim is that
you're a white person who thinks there
should be a country
just for white people or if you're a
white nationalist in america you think
america should just be for white people
or whatever the problem is there was a i
told this story before there was a guy
from the boston globe who wrote that the
based stick man you remember him right
yeah they said he was a deep lore right
like way back in the day they said he
was a white nationalist and i said he
wasn't he was in a relationship with an
asian woman had a mixed-race kid
and um the guy goes well he's white
right i was like well he's a white guy
yeah he's a nationalist right hmm yes
he's a white nationalist there you go
yeah that is the dirty game they play
see now you can't sue them
describe the color of someone's skin and
then say that they're you know ian you
uh uh you believe in freedom i do
you're you're you're a white freedomist
oh wait well let's slow this down a
little bit because
first of all
no human is white or black my favorite
one is in canada there's this story
about all these mass graves that were
discovered
yeah so there's no actual mass graves
discovered by the u.n standard mass
grave you know it's multiple bodies
buried in one area after like some sort
of war crime you know nefarious killings
that have happened they've they actually
found some graveyards some are just made
up others are graveyards that have lost
the markings because a lot of people
used poor catholics and indigenous
communities used wooden crosses and they
called these all mass graves a genocide
committed by canada wow our prime
minister
and they gave 27 yeah catholic schools
they
and
near residential schools but in some
cases the residential schools were built
like 13 years after the graveyard was
even there they were saying that like
nuns were executing children and burying
them in unmarked graves our mainstream
media literally was saying that um
they were interviewing people saying the
the nuns were throwing babies in the
incinerator under the school like this
is serious stuff and they have 27
million dollars for the investigation
mass graves on every headline and if you
question any of them about it a few like
new york times and stuff took away the
word mass graves they were like oh
that's wrong um i questioned someone
about it and they're like well it's a
graveyard isn't it so there's graves
there and there's a it's large a lot of
people which means mass
it's a massive grave like like they had
a funeral mass before they were buried
by mass graves right but it is it is a
mass grave that just doesn't mean that
they were executed
well but when people use their mass
grave they're referring specifically to
a giant hole that is dug to throw a
bunch of bodies in there so you can hide
the evidence that you murdered because a
graveyard is not a mass grave right
right this was a graveyard it wasn't
necessarily hide the evidence but you do
what i mean putting people in unmarked
grace there were no people like it's not
about hiding evidence it's like
literally just dumping bodies
carelessly yeah all right here we go
roman says when a co-worker proudly
tells me they're a communist and then
shames me for voting for trump my mind
goes blank what would you say this
happens to me all the time in california
i would say okay
like if i worked at a company and
someone walked up to me and said tim and
i said yes i'm a communist i would go
okay and they would say you voted for
trump and i'd like yes that's stupid i'd
be like okay
i don't know what i i don't know what i
wouldn't say i'd be like
i would be if someone's no conversation
i'm a communist the first thing i say is
what's it like to be a communist
that's a good one actually that's a good
that's a great response because i don't
think they could give you any real
experience as to what it means to be a
common also if someone ever asks you if
you're in a conversation someone's like
you don't know about fill in the blank
say should i
and it puts them on the defensive well
should i say yes but tell me about it
yeah then it can be legitimate like
educate yourself go google it yeah it's
not my job to do the emotional labor of
instructing you
that's it is what they say
all right here we go um hackerman says
to lauren are you still legally a man in
ontario i don't know some people's
gender changes with the day or whether
mine's location based really cool so
yeah i actually like i have the
identification that says mail i had to
get legal i'd get diagnosed by a doctor
as a male first and then go to like the
canadian version of dmv to get it
officiated diagnosed as a male what a
term that happened to most of us much
earlier
as soon as i was born got that diagnosis
all right let's see we got here
chris uh what does it say chris stoking
says christo king says as a poll i hope
nato puts troops in ukraine for defense
russia needs the needs the government
reform not ukraine
interesting
i was wondering what pol people in
poland think it's been amazing poland
and hungary have taken in like mass
amounts of refugees and they've done a
lot of support for the ukrainian people
and they've always been portrayed as
like oh you guys hate refugees you don't
support anyone they've completely opened
their borders for these ukrainian
refugees it's specifically because
they're culturally similar right and is
that a bad thing i don't think they
speak basically the same language so so
it has nothing to do with them being
anti-refugee or anything it's completely
about yeah just people that are
yeah refugees assimilate to their
culture
well i don't want to point out any
particular person but someone that
doesn't identify with the culture
christianity things like that i
understand that now
jeffrey faulkner says facebook is having
trouble tonight possible cyber attack
it could be i mean to be honest you
wouldn't know
you would not know
we were having internet issues and every
so often you'll see major internet
outages
and what y'all need to understand is
that if um
if say china were to hit the us internet
for five minutes a day every day for two
years
that adds up in economic damage and if
they're trying to grow their economy
faster than ours it adds up oh wow
traffic siege warfare that's right
so look if if we're if we're imagine the
cold war the us and russia are trying to
gain territory imagine it was digital
and you could stop them in their tracks
by you know activating code
why wouldn't you
so you don't need to destroy their
infrastructure overnight you just need
to stagger their growth enough so that
you can become a lot bigger and then
absorb them and shut them down so this
is an interesting thing i've observed
when i speak to military friends of mine
they tell me how valuable technology
that has no computers in it is like
having a car that has no computer in it
and even just so like i had a few
friends they drove into a river and the
water started coming up and they luckily
had rolled down windows instead of
electric windows and saved their asses
and a lot of countries when you have
like warfare going on you want that
stuff that's not going to fail you want
stuff that you can't like boom short
circuit the computer like take it over
so having older technology can actually
be like the way to get around that a lot
of troops would use like systems to
place everyone but now they're having to
go back and learn navigation so that
their stuff can't be hacked and tracked
where the troops are oh wow yeah it's
fascinating
all right remy says a site called nuke
map has an overlay where you can pick a
location and select any nuke dropped or
tested to see if
see the fireball radius blast radius
radiation etc
yes you know radiation's intentional
that they they make nukes that have no
radiation
that's on purpose they want
people to suffer
that's nice
yeah man it's not good the best if if
you're in the blast radius or you're in
like the radio you're probably better
off in the blast radius than the
radiation radio like radius this one's
calculating i went to nuke radzone.org
nuke map it says nucle downtown
manhattan it doesn't go from river to
river the blast zone well which have you
chosen you can chose for me yeah pick
like sarvama perhaps i spoke too soon
it's it's too complicated for me right
now oh see there you go nuke map
nuke map eh cool idea
jeff depkin says churchill and coventry
due to the allies cracking the enigma
machine they knew coventry would be
bombed churchill did nothing to avoid
giving away the fact that they had
cracked the code
hmm
man
david miller says don't know tim but i
remember when he was in ny at at uh at
that shooting and that shooting and that
shooting when he was in new york and
that shooting in your apartment was that
the one at my apartment i was like
sitting in my boxers playing destiny the
video game the space fantasy one a dude
shot in my apartment in new york too it
wasn't in my apartment a helicopter it
was downstairs right over my house my
apartment i was like well i looked
outside and i got a text and they were
like are you near the shooting i was
like what and then i look and i see cops
everywhere and the street lights are
like shut off and you know two cops got
executed i got home and there was a
police tape around my apartment they're
like dude the dude downstairs got shot
from a drug deal gone wrong and they
wouldn't let me inside
new york city
all right doreen de leonard de leonardo
says
gary null is suing wikipedia reach out
to him and join his effort have him on
as a guest p.s we love your show tim hey
appreciate it
gary all right gary let's hang out
seriously jk says did you see the lex
friedman zuckerberg interview it was the
creepiest creepy that ever created so
interesting i heard that uh uh he failed
the turing test
it was two ai going crazy together i
loved it i saw about 40 minutes or 30
minutes of it so far and it seems like
mark one of the things that he said that
was notable two things one thing he said
he's obsessed and wants creative
commerce it's a big part of the future
of the meta versus creative commerce
mark what you need to know is that child
slavery is also a form of creative
commerce kids are being rocked on roblox
right now getting 17 there about of the
money that roblox has taken in from the
games they make that's creative commerce
so you got to watch out second is
he finally mark now understands he used
to think everyone should have one
identity on the internet and now he's
looking at people should have masses of
um
anonymous identities as well which i
think is a huge breakthrough for the
mindset of the guy that's running
facebook right now
kosh naranek says come on tim i want to
hear you say big chungus
well there you go what did you just say
we have a really good idea sheamus we
have a really good idea oh yeah we want
we want to make a show called mall store
uh a new youtube channel and the idea is
we were at the mall
and
that was like crappy arcade that was
like half broken and i was like we
should open a mall store and do weird
things with it and so the idea is we
would run out of space it would be
called mall store dude but then what we
do is like once a week we change the
advertisement oh my goodness so we had
one my brother's idea was to put a
laundromat in the middle of a mall
because then you have to like come with
your dirty laundry into a shopping mall
and like walk into a mall you just like
weird things like that dude we should
have one and call it aquarium and just
put a bunch of dogs with snorkels inside
uh tanks of water and just see if
anyone's willing to say anything you
just have a bunch of people and they're
fantastic
yeah exactly and have people there like
pretending that they are acknowledging
it's an aquarium like you you hire
people to be like whoa look at the fish
and see how many people
this is a level they're willing to say
something comprehensive it's not that
expensive
it's it's it's it's like you could rent
them all because you were banned from
patreon for water boxes
this is like the
they've gone too far science has gone
too far the mind of
did
man
hear about that guy who created
hampshire like rapture from bioshock but
with hamsters under a lake
under a lake well he was trying to put
it he started building it in like little
tanks and stuff and his idea was he was
going to build it under a lake i can
certainly understand that sheamus
talking about getting a bunch of
underwater dogs with snorkels and tanks
it's very expensive in tanks i was
thinking it's not that you just you go
to go to a rescue shelter and borrow
something i was thinking it'd be fun to
find homes for them we could we could do
kind of like social experiments one idea
what idea i had was was to put up a
sunset free wallet and it's an empty
mall store with lights cameras in the
corners and there's a wallet sitting on
a pedestal right in the middle of the
room
with like a guy's id in it and like
credit cards and money just to see what
people would do something like that like
what's the catch i think it's brilliant
no i think i think that's a great idea
so wait how often would well how often
would it be a new store there the idea
is we would do a video once a week where
we do some kind of social experiment in
mall store okay so every every week so
like changes that's brilliant like one
of the ideas we had was a store called
ian's things
and it's just like ian's stuff and like
pictures of him
imagine posters in the windows of ian
modeling his own clothes like this shirt
right he was like 20 years old my dad
gave it to me and ian is just at the
cash register like haggling with people
over the prices of things like that he's
like i'll give i guess like 15 bucks
craigslist in real life
one of the other ideas was um
to take mandates to the to
to the absurd degree so like you got to
get swabbed you've got to get tested you
have to wear a full hazmat suit but we
sell things really really cheap so we
would do like at cost iphones
but you got to come in a full hazmat
suit
it's a mandate we're a private business
we can do what we want and see how many
people are willing to jump through the
hoops to get it you should have a use
the mask store like use covet masks be
like no i mean it's it's for the science
the sun says it works and they're
cheaper in japan when i was in japan
they had used girls panties
[Applause]
like vending machines yeah and they'd
have pictures of the girls that used the
panties on it and like anybody like 14
years old man makes horrors beyond our
comprehension
so
can we talk about this later tonight
that's crazy you don't know about japan
dude we're doing an aftershock
people all right everybody all right
everybody smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
if you like it go to timcast.com because
we're going to carry the conversation
over to the members only section where
ian has some very interesting questions
i guess goodness and uh yeah but we we
we're gonna talk about the refugee
processing at the border um because some
of these countries are just banning
black people from from coming in but
what they're really saying is it's for
the the local population not for
migrants so we will talk about that
it'll be interesting again go to
timcast.com become a member you can
follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere you can follow me
at tim cast lauren do you have anything
to shout out yeah i mean check my
socials at lauren underscore southern on
twitter lauren southern on youtube i'll
be announcing my new film american
mirage soon uh it'll hopefully be on
odyssey youtube all that good stuff and
thank you for having me on it's been too
long it's been years since we've seen
each other yeah
well you're in another congratulations
on everything you've done thank you
incredible you haven't even we yeah we
haven't gotten the full tour yet i'm
excited all right you came from carrying
that gopro on the ground everywhere
truly like made it from the bottom to
the top well here we go we got a lot
more to do
i'm seamus coughlin i'm here to promote
my upcoming show mall store we're going
to be opening our a used grocery store
for lightly used and refurbished
groceries that's a good idea let's do it
now i have i have a youtube channel
called freedom tunes we upload a new
cartoon every single thursday sometimes
on tuesdays as well i also like to hang
out here do commentary join the podcast
and help with the vlog so i highly
recommend you guys check out freedom
tunes i think you'll enjoy it and i hope
you all have a lovely rest of your night
i love you everyone thanks for coming
lauren great to meet you and see you
finally
you know i'm a light jedi in that way
they use flame instead of electric
current
see you later
and i gotta fix my camera i don't know
if you guys know but i can't do this
unless it's visible to me so here's the
wide shot sorry can't you just press a
preset
which is is that the wide shot that's it
yeah so idea right there looking at us
doesn't feel like an invasion of your
privacy yeah i like when i'm like moving
around i know i know
lydia can see everything you're saying
about her from that camera everything i
was only texting about lydia the whole
time i know understandable sheamus i was
gonna say there i have actually been to
stores where you can buy slightly used
groceries that are like maybe expired or
stop it
expired is not used expired is not you i
can tell you some stories about stuff in
chicago man yeah same idea
i never saw any of that yeah so i'm
sorry to take the window to your sales i
think that sounds like a great show
anyway you guys thank you so much for
tuning in for our third swatting i think
we get like a prize once we hit five or
something free yogurt yeah like a free
yogurt yeah anyway you guys can follow
me on twitter and mines.com
we will see all of you at timcast.com
around 11 for that member segment you
don't want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all there
you